Hi everybody, how was your day today? Are you asking us or the audience and you're expecting an answer from you? No, the audience is not Mike. You got sorry. Well, no, I was asked. Oh, they're not since when you call me and JB everybody. Yeah. No, I call you guys the audience because you think that's the only people listening to you is just us too.
大家好，今天过得怎么样？你是问我们还是问听众，期待听众给你回答吗？不，听众不是迈克。不好意思。好吧，不，我被问了。哦，他们不是，你从什么时候开始叫我和JB大家的。对。不，我叫你们听众，因为你觉得唯一在听的人只有我们两个。
Yeah, you got higher responsibilities in that. Let's come with the good stuff. Judging by this opening we're after, it's going to be a great Smartless. Welcome to it. It's ISU, Illinois State University, where I have an honorary doctorate and a scholarship fund set up for people who want to go into music or the arts and sorry, acting. Are they still accredited? I mean after you got a diploma, I heard that after they give you a diploma that they were stripped of their power was like a real on Is that an online universe? Oh, I still wear my sash to bed once they did an assessment of your intellect
对，你的责任更大。咱们聊点有意思的吧。从这个开场来看，今天的《聪明无智》绝对错不了。欢迎收听。这是伊利诺伊州立大学，我在那儿有荣誉博士学位，还设立了一个奖学金基金，资助那些想从事音乐、艺术或者抱歉，表演的人。他们现在还有资格认证吗？我是说，在你拿到毕业证之后，我听说他们发完毕业证之后就被剥夺了资质，就像那种真正的，那是个在线大学吗？哦，我睡觉时还会戴着饰带呢，他们对你的智力进行评估之后
They're like we gave this guy a fucking diploma Did you really go to ISU? I went to Illinois State University. Yes, the one of the greatest colleges ever. Okay Well, hang on. Let's quickly Google that I don't think you're gonna like first theater theater, by the way, you know who went there me Jane Lynch Craig Robinson And I were music majors together. No, we I know we've had them on the podcast I know we talked about that. We talked about for like half an hour. Hey Arnett. Where'd you go to school? I did it. I dropped out man.nett. Where'd you go to school? I did it I dropped out man. No, but they you did go to boarding school. You know where I went
他们就像是，我们居然给这家伙发了该死的毕业证！你真的去过伊利诺伊州立大学吗？我去了伊利诺伊州立大学。是的，那是史上最伟大的大学之一。好吧，等等。让我们赶紧谷歌一下。我觉得你不会喜欢，首先是戏剧，顺便说一句，你知道谁去过那里吗？我、简·林奇、克雷格·罗宾逊。我们以前是一起学音乐的。不，我知道我们在播客里提过。我知道我们聊过这个。我们聊了大概半小时。嘿，阿内特。你是在哪儿上学的？我没上，兄弟。阿内特。你是在哪儿上学的？我没上，我辍学了，兄弟。不，但是你们确实上过寄宿学校。你知道我去哪儿吗？
I went to fucking hard knocks, dude Streets hard not life with Annie Toronto. Yeah, well streets of Toronto. Did you go do you went you went to use me you? Excuse me. You went to additional additional voluntary school. I did for half a half a year Yeah, I know I love you You went to additional voluntary school? I did for half a year. I know, I love that you go to additional voluntary. No, actually I should revert that. Voluntary additional school. And I just didn't understand the concept of that.
我经历过社会的毒打，老兄。残酷的街头生活，和安妮·多伦多一起。Yeah，好吧，多伦多的街道。你去过，你去过，你去过，你上过。不好意思。你去过附加志愿学校。我去了半年。是的，我知道，我爱你。你去过附加志愿学校？我去了半年。我知道，我喜欢你这种“附加志愿”的说法。不，其实我应该纠正一下。是志愿附加学校。而我当时根本不理解那个概念。
Well yeah. I now have an option to not go so taking that option Sure, you're in a good joke. Yeah, sure. Love one ISU Just jump in. I didn't realize that you were grabbing the reins here We were just merrily going down a path, but I knew it's like, errrr, let's just go fucking, okay Let's talk more about your school. I didn't go. No, that's not. Here we go ready The best gift I ever received was a broken drum. You can't beat it Okay, that's all right, that's okay. He doesn't claim that these to be great jokes
好吧，是的。我现在有了不去的选择，所以我就选了不去。当然，你开得一手好玩笑。对，当然。我爱伊利诺伊州立大学，直接切入正题吧。我没意识到你在这儿掌握着方向盘呢。我们本来只是高高兴兴地沿着一条路走，但我知道这就像，呃，让我们去他妈的，好吧。我们多聊聊你的学校吧。我没去。不，不是这样。我们开始吧，准备好。我收到的最好的礼物是一个破鼓。你绝对敲不出比这更好的了。好吧，没关系，这还可以。他可不自称这些是绝妙的笑话。
Oh, yeah, I got a couple laughs in the background there you should you should say do you want to hear a dad joke if you say? Ready for something good dad joke means it's not like the term dad joke I think that that's I think that's lazy to call it a dad joke. How about bad joke? Just say bad joke so people aren't expecting to laugh. Or like a pun. That's okay to say. I got one more, you got one more.
哦，是的，背景里有几个人笑了，你应该说，你想听个冷笑话吗？如果你说，准备好听个好笑的冷笑话了，这就意味着它不像“冷笑话”这个词，我觉得叫它“冷笑话”太偷懒了。不如叫“烂笑话”？直接说烂笑话，这样大家就不会抱有大笑的期待了。或者像个双关语。这样说也可以。我还有一个，你还有一个。
Are there any mom jokes? Here's a mom joke. What's faster, hot or cold? Hot, you can always catch a cold. That's good, that's good. Is that bad? That's pretty good. I guarantee you at least one of our listeners
有什么“妈妈笑话”吗？这是一个妈妈笑话。哪个更快，热还是冷？热，因为你随时都能“感冒”（catch a cold，双关“着凉”）。这不错，这不错。这很烂吗？这挺好的。我保证我们至少有一个听众
will be using that today after they get out of their car or off their subway or done with their jog. It's fun. You're welcome. I love, hang on Sean, I love Jason Cheyenne to imagine what regular people do. It's so fun. They get on the subway and then they go. They kiss their kids goodbye,
今天下车、出地铁或慢跑结束后会用这个梗。挺有意思的。不客气。等等，肖恩，我喜欢想象杰森和夏安想象普通人是怎么生活的。太有趣了。他们坐地铁，然后去上班。他们亲吻孩子们告别，
walk out door, go to job, say hi boss, office. Want to hear a joke? Want to hear a joke? At water cooler with me. I love Succession 2. What are you watching? I'm also watching Succession. Are you watching it? I am also worried about saying that I don't like it. Do you're worried that you're saying I do like it I'm just alright the joke real real good opening pattern everybody did everybody sleep well. I slept really well Patters over let's get to a high-level guest. Okay, really good though Did you for the first actually that that is worth itail. You wanna talk to us about your sleep? The guest is not gonna wait for your sleep report.
走出门，去上班，对老板说声嗨，在办公室。想听个笑话吗？想听个笑话？在饮水机旁对我说。我太喜欢《继承之战》第二季了。你在看什么？我也在看《继承之战》。你在看吗？我也很担心说我不喜欢它。你担心你说的是我喜欢它，我只是好吧，这个笑话真的很不错，开场节奏大家都睡得好吗。我睡得真好。闲聊结束，我们来请一位高水平的嘉宾吧。好吧，真的很不错。你，为了第一其实这真的很值得。你想跟我们聊聊你的睡眠吗？嘉宾可不会等你汇报睡眠情况。
Well it's very rare that he has good sleep. Before we get into it, it is true Sean, and I'm happy for you, and there's nobody, we talk about it all the time. Sean, yesterday morning JB, Sean, I said to him, hey you got a second, let me know when you got a second, like seven, I'm up at six, I said let me know when you got a second. It was like seven. It was at seven, he calls me, and I thought that him, hey, you got a second, let me know when you got a second, like seven, I'm up at six, I said let me know when you got a second. It was like seven.
好吧，他睡眠质量好可是非常罕见的。在我们深入正题之前，确实如此，肖恩，我为你感到高兴，而且没有人，我们经常谈论这个。肖恩，昨天早上JB，肖恩，我对他说，嘿，你有一会儿空吗，有空的时候告诉我一声，大概七点，我六点就醒了，我说有空告诉我一声。大概七点。大约七点时，他给我打电话，我以为他会，嘿，你有一会儿空吗，有空的时候告诉我一声，大概七点，我六点就醒了，我说有空告诉我一声。大概七点。
It was at seven, he calls me. And I thought that he was back, you know his usual thing, he wakes up in the middle of the night, and then he goes back to bed at 6.30 until 10 is whatever. He was up and he'd been up since 3.30. 3.30 in the night. He's been on a bad run of not being able to sleep, so. So I slept all through the night,
大约七点，他给我打电话。我以为他像往常一样，你知道他那老一套，半夜醒来，然后从六点半又睡到十点什么的。他当时已经醒了，而且从三点半就醒了。半夜三点半。他最近睡眠状态一直很糟糕，所以。所以我整晚都在睡觉，
I got up to pee and I went right back to sleep. And why do you think think that is did you load up on a bunch of sugar before you went to bed? I did a little bit but because of Yesterday, I think that what wills talking about I think I ran myself around in circles like a little child Being up at 330 and then I just crashed and it made me sleep all night long. It's awesome You know what a fucking story It was awesome. You nap. What a fucking story. I'll nap like ten minutes.
我起来上个厕所然后就立马接着睡着了。你觉得这是为什么呢？难道你睡觉前吃了一堆糖吗？我吃了一点点，但因为昨天的事，我想这就是威尔所说的，我觉得我像个小孩子一样把自己折腾得团团转，三点半就醒了，然后直接累瘫了，这让我睡了个整觉。太棒了。你知道这算什么狗屁故事。太棒了。你小睡一会儿。算什么狗屁故事。我小睡个十分钟。
I'll nap like ten minutes. Anyway, so. Good that we stopped for that. You were right, Will. Silly me. So today's guest is so immensely accomplished. We're gonna see David's face. What a fucking story.
我小睡个十分钟。不管怎样，所以。幸亏我们停下来聊了这个。你是对的，威尔。我真傻。所以今天的嘉宾成就非凡。我们要见到大卫的脸了。算什么狗屁故事。
God, who else slept through the whole night? Make sure you call in. Our lines are open. And love to hear about it. So our next guest is so accomplished and so universally loved. Okay? He's so accomplished and so universally loved. He's done everything. He's done television, film, theater. He's even got a Grammy, I believe.
天哪，还有谁一觉睡到天亮的？记得打电话进来。我们的热线开通着。很想听听大家的经历。所以我们的下一位嘉宾成就非凡，而且深受所有人喜爱。好吗？他成就非凡，而且深受所有人喜爱。他什么都做过。他做过电视、电影、戏剧。我相信他甚至还拿过格莱美奖。
It's been comedy, it's been drama, it's been popcorn movies, it's been academy movies. I just don't know what else to say about this fella except he's a new friend. Oh. Okay. Okay. We met online. And he is also a Capricorn.
有喜剧，有剧情，有爆米花电影，也有颁奖季电影。除了他是一位新朋友，我真不知道还能怎么评价这家伙。哦。好吧。好吧。我们是在网上认识的。而且他还是个摩羯座。
And no, he is a new friend that I'm very excited about. He swings a mean golf club. Oh, I thought we were gonna say both. The way that started was he swings. I know. I know. I was like, oh, what? He'll take you where you want to go on the weekends. Okay, well, that's what I'm saying. But listen, I love him. He's here.
不，他是位新朋友，我对此非常兴奋。他挥得一手好高尔夫球杆。哦，我还以为我们要一起说呢。一开始的那种说法是他挥杆。我知道。我知道。我当时想，哦，什么？周末他会带你去你想去的地方。好吧，这就是我要说的。但是听着，我爱他。他来了。
Very kind of him to say yes, because this is a big shot. Ladies and gentlemen, Mr. Don Cheadle. Hello, Don. I. Don Cheadle. Hello, Don. Oh, I love Don Cheadle. People. Woo! What's happening?
他能答应真是太好了，因为这是个大人物。女士们先生们，唐·钱德尔先生。你好，唐。我。唐·钱德尔。你好，唐。哦，我爱唐·钱德尔。各位。哇！怎么回事？
Good morning. Don. Don Cheadle's done everything. You know what I was trying to remember, Don? What is that great nickname that you were given because you're so smooth? I couldn't remember it. You told me this on the golf course.
早上好。唐。唐·钱德尔什么都做过。你知道我一直在试图想起什么吗，唐？别人因为你太淡定而送你的那个伟大的绰号是什么？我记不起来了。你在高尔夫球场上跟我说过这个。
I think Kelly Slater said that was very Don Shallant. Yeah! Don Shallant! Is that a new nickname? That's really clever. I'm trying to put it out there. I was going to try to trademark it, but I was unsuccessful. Don Shallant is out there now, just FYI.
我想凯利·斯莱特说过，那非常“唐·若·淡定”（Don Shallant）。对！唐·若·淡定！这是一个新绰号吗？这真的太巧妙了。我正试图把它推广出去。我本来想去注册商标，但没成功。唐·若·淡定现在已经传开了，顺便告诉你们一声。
It's fully out there, and if you happen to run into Don Chilon in the streets, just immediately, Don Chilon. Yeah. Let him know. Mr. Chilon. You can single gun it or double gun it. I don't know. Wow. Okay.
它已经完全传开了，如果你恰巧在街上遇到唐·若·淡定，那就马上，唐·若·淡定。是的。让他知道。钱德尔先生。你可以单手开枪或者双手开枪。我不知道。哇。好吧。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Don. Don Chilon, hi. Good morning. What's up, gang? I love Don Cheadle. You know, the team was like, you've got to do these guys' podcasts. You're going to love them. I love all of you individually and collectively.
对。对。对。唐。唐·若·淡定，嗨。早上好。大家怎么说？我爱唐·钱德尔。你知道，团队当时说，你一定要上这几个家伙的播客。你会喜欢他们的。我爱你们每一个人，无论是单独还是集体。
Not as much when it's that through the banter. The early banter. It's like, remember the joy that Regis and Kathie Lee used to give you with that first 10 minutes of coffee powder? I love it. Right? Yeah. I love it.
当有这些插科打诨时就没那么爱了。早期的插科打诨。这就像，还记得里吉斯和凯茜·李在咖啡秀的前十分钟带给你的那种快乐吗？我喜欢。对吧？对。我喜欢。
I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. the early banter. It's like, remember the joy that Regis and Kathie Lee used to give you with that first 10 minutes
我喜欢。我喜欢。我喜欢。我喜欢。我喜欢。我喜欢。我喜欢。我喜欢。我喜欢。我喜欢。我喜欢。早期的插科打诨。这就像，还记得里吉斯和凯茜·李在咖啡秀的前十分钟带给你的那种快乐吗
of coffee powder? Yeah. That's what we're reaching for, Don. No, it was a strong six minutes. Don, where are we finding you right now? And the reason I ask is because you look like you're either coming from or going to the golf course because you're wearing a zip-up, but I want to say, which is surprising, because you look like you're either coming from or going to the golf course because you're wearing a zip up. But I want to say, which is surprising,
咖啡秀？对。这就是我们所追求的，唐。不，这绝对有扎实的六分钟。唐，我们现在是在哪里联系到你的？我这么问是因为你看起来要么是从高尔夫球场来，要么正要去高尔夫球场，因为你穿着一件拉链衫，但我想说，这让人很意外，因为你看起来要么是从高尔夫球场来，要么正要去高尔夫球场，因为你穿着一件拉链衫。但我想说，这让人很意外，
because you are such, you're so busy and rightfully so, because you're always, you fit in that category for me too, of people who are always good no matter what the project is. You're so consistently awesome all the time. And you work- Wait until you see this one. Who's gonna take that down? I don't know.
因为你太，你太忙了，而且理应如此，因为你总是，你也符合我心中的那一类演员，无论什么项目，你总是表现出色。你一直都如此 consistently awesome（持续地惊艳）。而且你工作——等着看这一个。谁能把这个接住？我不知道。
Quick. You know what, you know what I just watched just last week, not even knowing obviously that we were gonna be on because you're Jason's guest, we watched Mission to Mars. I was in there. And I was like, there's Don, again, and you're brilliant in it. Always.
快。你知道吗，你知道我上周刚看了一部电影吗？甚至都不知道我们会上节目，因为你是杰森的嘉宾，我们看了《火星任务》。我在里面。然后我就想，唐又出现了，你在里面演得太棒了。总是如此。
Always brilliant. Because you know I'll watch anything sci-fi. I am picking up on surprise in Sean's voice though. And he says, and you're brilliant. It was like, you were pretty good. No, I meant to Will's point. I didn't know you were an actor. And that you could grow facial hair.
总是那么棒。因为你知道我会看任何科幻片。不过我确实察觉到肖恩语气里的惊讶了。他说，而且你演得真棒。听起来就像，你其实演得还挺好。不，我是针对威尔的观点。我不知道你是个演员。而且你还能留面部毛发。
I thought it was only Jason who could do that. This is not really facial hair. This is disgusting. No, it was great. So, Don. I'm in Atlanta, Will, to answer your question No, it was great. Well, so, Don. I'm in Atlanta, Will, to answer your question, I'm in Atlanta. You're in Atlanta.
我以为只有杰森能做到这一点。这其实不是面部毛发。这太恶心了。不，这很棒。所以，唐。我在亚特兰大，威尔，回答你的问题。不，这很棒。那么，唐。我在亚特兰大，威尔，回答你的问题，我在亚特兰大。你在亚特兰大。
And what's happening there in Atlanta? Working on something, no doubt? I'm working on something, it's a project called Fight Night. And I am in this wonderful project with who you guys had on the show, Kevin Hart. Sam Jackson. Taraji Henson, Terrence Howard. Wow. Yeah, it should be, I'm looking forward to it. I've shot one day, so I'm looking forward to this journey.
亚特兰大那边在发生什么？毫无疑问在拍什么项目吧？我正在拍一部作品，一个叫《搏击之夜》的项目。我参与了这个美妙的项目，里面有你们在节目里采访过的凯文·哈特。萨姆·杰克逊。塔拉吉·汉森，泰伦斯·霍华德。哇。是的，应该会很棒，我很期待这段旅程。我已经拍了一天了，所以我很期待接下来的旅程。
You can still be fired. They can still easily reshoot one day at work. Yeah, it's early enough. Yeah, so watch it. I've been replaced before. It wouldn't be the first time. enough. Yeah, so watch it. I've been replaced before. It wouldn't be the first time. Have you? No.
你还是有被开除的可能。他们随时都可以轻易地重拍工作的第一天。是的，时间还早。所以小心点。我以前被替换过。这可不是第一次了。时间还早。所以小心点。我以前被替换过。这可不是第一次了。你被替换过？没有。
Have you? I've been replaced before. I have. I didn't mean to bring up something pink. Oh wait, I love that Don's like, no. I haven't, sorry, I was just kidding you. Of course not. Mine was a, why do you think I'm on your show?
你被替换过？我被替换过。我有过。我本来不是想提起什么伤心事的。哦等等，我喜欢唐那种“没有”的语气。我没有，抱歉，我刚才是开玩笑的。当然没有。我经历的那次，你为什么觉得我会上你们节目？
Mine was a cruelest though, because I worked my nards off on this pilot, we shot the pilot, it went well, so I thought, and then like a couple of days before the big announcements happen about whether pilots are gonna get picked up to go to series, I get a call from my agent saying, you are going to, good news, bad news, good news is the show got picked up.
我那次可残酷了，因为我为这个试播集付出了血汗，我们拍了试播集，进展很顺利，我是这么认为的，然后就在关于试播集是否会被选为系列剧的大消息宣布前几天，我接到了经纪人的电话，他说，你将要听到好消息和坏消息，好消息是这个剧被选中了。
And I said, unbelievable, he, goes here, let me finish. The bad news is that they're gonna go a different direction with your character. I said, okay. Two days later, found out they're actually not picking up the show. So could you, I mean, this is like the worst 48 hours. So good, bad, good.
我说，太不可思议了，他说，等等，让我说完。坏消息是他们打算对你的角色采取不同的方向。我说，好吧。两天后，我发现他们其实根本没有选定这个剧。所以你能，我的意思是，这就像是最糟糕的48小时。所以好，坏，好。
Good, bad, good. I agree with Don. I could have been spared all of it by just them saying, well we're not picking up the show. Basically, we're all fired. You know? Are you still with this agent? Yeah, that's gonna be a good thing.
好，坏，好。我同意唐的看法。如果他们直接说，嗯，我们不拍这个剧了，那我就可以省去这一切了。基本上，我们都被解雇了。你知道吗？你还在跟这个经纪人合作吗？对，那将是一件好事。
Yeah, exactly. No, no, no. That's three or four ago. But it's good to know, I like it is personal a little bit because they were like, hey, we know the show's not getting picked up, but let's let Bateman know that even if it did, he wasn't coming with you. Yeah.
对，没错。不，不，不。那是三四年前的事了。但很高兴知道，我喜欢它有点私人色彩，因为他们就像是，嘿，我们知道这个剧不会被选中，但让我们告诉贝特曼，即使被选中了，他也不会跟你一起去。 yeah。
In the event that this is going forward, not you. I've been fired too. I got fired off a pilot that went to series the year before we started Arrested Development. Oh, God bless. And had I not been, I would have been stuck on that show. Don, wait a second. So you're in Atlanta, you're doing this thing with Sam Jackson. Are you potentially playing golf with Sam today? You know, Sam has been on IR for a minute.
万一这个项目继续推进，也没有你。我也被炒过鱿鱼。在开始拍《发展受阻》的前一年，我被一部拍成系列剧的试播集给开除了。哦，天哪。如果我没有被开除，我就会被困在那部剧里了。唐，等一下。所以你在亚特兰大，你跟萨姆·杰克逊一起在搞这个东西。你今天有可能跟萨姆打高尔夫球吗？你知道，萨姆因为伤病已经休息一会儿了。
I hope he comes off because I would love to. We used to play a lot, but he's nursing an injury or two. Fingers crossed. How's his game? Sam was like a four. What? Wow. Yeah.
我希望他能复出，因为我很想去。我们以前经常一起打，但他正在养一两个伤。祈祷一切顺利吧。他的水平怎么样？萨姆以前大概是个4差点。什么？哇。
Damn it. Wow. There's all these people. The game is just so easy to so many people. Well, you know, Sam, famously, you know, whenever he would get a gig, a part of his contract was they had to get him a membership to whatever local course there was because he's such a freak about it. So he...
妈的。哇。有这么多人。这项运动对许多人来说太简单了。好吧，你知道，众所周知的萨姆，每当他接工作时，他合同的一部分就是他们必须给他办一张当地任何球场的会员卡，因为他对高尔夫球太狂热了。所以他……
Oh really, no shit? Yeah, he played everywhere. I was like, you can do that? Sam also was, you know, Mr. If you force me, you're bringing me $900 in cash in an envelope the next day like a drug deal. I was like, this dude's my hero. Yeah.
哦真的吗，不是吧？对，他到处打球。我当时想，你还能这样？萨姆也是那种，你知道的，先生：如果你逼我，你第二天就会像进行毒品交易一样，用信封给我带来900美元现金。我当时想，这家伙是我的偶像。对。
By the way, Jason, you can, Jason right now, you see he looked down, he's got, he's just gone on his phone, you know, speed dialed the CAA right now. He you look down he's he's got he's just gone his phone speed down to CAA right now I think like what the fuck 12 country club short damn it Yeah, all right now, how do you like how do you like Atlanta? You know I've worked there a lot and and I always I always thought that it was not gonna be a place for me
顺便说一句，杰森，你可以，杰森现在，你看他低头了，他有，他刚刚拿出手机，你知道的，现在正给CAA（创新艺人经纪公司）打快速拨号。你看他低头了，他有，他刚刚拿出手机，现在正给CAA打快速拨号，我心想，什么鬼，12家乡村俱乐部，太可恶了！好吧，那么，你觉得亚特兰大怎么样？你知道，我在那里工作过很多次，而且我一直以为那不会是一个适合我的地方。
And every time I work there, I just love it more and more and more. Do you enjoy yourself there? You've worked there a bunch, yes? I've worked here a bunch because a lot of the Marvel stuff was here. Right. Oh, right. And I've kinda been around it a little bit more, but this is probably the longest stretch
但每次我在那里工作，我都越来越喜欢它。你在那里过得开心吗？你在那里工作过很多次，对吧？我在那里工作过很多次，因为很多漫威的东西都在那里拍。对。哦，对。而且我对此有了更多了解，但这可能是呆得最长的一段时间，
that I'm gonna be here, so I'm looking forward to like getting up to the mountains and going to the lakes and just checking it all out. So I did a movie there a long time ago in Atlanta during the summer. Did you guys shoot all those Marvel movies in the summertime because you can't breathe, it's so hot. Hot Atlanta, hot Atlanta.
我将要在这里呆下去，所以我很期待去山上、去湖泊转转，把所有地方都看一看。所以我很久以前夏天在亚特兰大拍过一部电影。你们是不是所有漫威电影都在夏天拍的，因为热得根本喘不过气？炎热的亚特兰大，炎热的亚特兰大。
Yeah. And you're in those costumes and running around in that heat, is that what it... And you're in space? Yeah, I mean I think that was the... Oh, there's a callback. I have a callback. Good one. No, but I mean, isn't that brutal?
是的。而且你们穿着那些戏服在那样的酷热中跑来跑去，是这样的吗……而且你在太空中？是的，我的意思是，我想那就是……哦，有个梗。我接上梗了。干得好。不，我的意思是，这不是很残酷吗？
Yeah, it's brutal. I mean, I'm from Kansas City, Missouri, where 98 degrees and 98% humidity, so I was born for this, you know? But yeah, it's not fun. But right now, it's very cold, actually. It's very cold. I like it too.
是的，太残酷了。我是说，我来自密苏里州堪萨斯城，那里气温98华氏度，湿度98%，所以我生来就是干这个的，你知道吗？但是，是的，这并不好玩。但现在，实际上非常冷。非常冷。我也喜欢。
I like JB. I spent the last few years about, last year I spent six months, I think, almost in Atlanta. And I really liked it. I really liked the people. Once you find a kind of a good zone where you can find your stuff and whatever, I liked it a lot.
我喜欢JB。我过去几年里，去年我花了大概六个月，差不多在亚特兰大。我真的很喜欢那里。我真的很喜欢那里的人。一旦你找到了一个好地方，能找到你的归宿之类的，我就会非常喜欢。
You gotta find a zone. but I was down in like I was down like right near sort of little five points like all in there like that's where I was staying it was awesome a lot of great like restaurants and okay okay yeah yeah yeah so Jason if you had enough yeah you open it you open it you open it this it. This is like a fucking court case. You, good sleep last night, Don? You know, what's hilarious when Sean was talking about that is I was very jealous because I did not sleep well last night. That's what I'm saying. The fucking worst episode we've ever recorded.
你得找到一个属于自己的地方。但我当时住在类似于小五点附近，全都在那一带，我就是住在那里，太棒了，有很多很棒的餐馆和好吧，好吧，对，对，对。所以杰森，如果你受够了，对，你打开它，你打开它，你打开它，就是这样。这就像是一场该死的法庭诉讼。你昨晚睡得好吗，唐？你知道，当肖恩在谈论这个的时候，最搞笑的是我很嫉妒，因为我昨晚没睡好。这就是我要说的。我们录过的最烂的一集。
Right, we're right, we're 17 minutes into the worst. From what I did? No, no, it's all my fault, all my fault. I'm talking about fucking Atlanta. We're talking about the weather. We're talking about sleep. It's like, let's get to something hard hitting. Now somebody told me the other day that Kansas City...
对，我们，对，我们在最烂的一集里进行了17分钟了。是因为我做的吗？不，不，全都是我的错，全都是我的错。我们在聊该死的天气。我们在聊亚特兰大。我们在聊天气。我们在聊睡眠。这就像，让我们聊点有深度的话题吧。现在有人前几天告诉我，堪萨斯城……
Oh, here we go. Kansas City is actually split right down the middle, the border between Kansas and Missouri. You still don't have it. J.K.B., you still don't have it. No? You still haven't got it. J.B., you still don't have it. No? You still haven't got it. That's a whiff. No.
哦，开始了。堪萨斯城其实是从正中间被一分为二的，位于堪萨斯州和密苏里州的边界上。你还是没明白。J.K.B.，你还是没明白。没吗？你还是没懂。J.B.，你还是没懂。没吗？你还是没懂。这是个空挥。不。
Help me. People? No, no, no. There's one in Kansas and there's a Kansas City and Missouri there. I mean, they're close. Wait, there's two different places called Kansas City. Oh my God. No, honestly.
帮帮我。人们？不，不，不。有一个在堪萨斯州，还有一个堪萨斯城在密苏里州。我是说，它们很近。等等，有两个不同的地方都叫堪萨斯城？哦，天哪。不，说实话。
I know. John's about to leave. John, this is every day, by the way. This is how it goes. 54 years old and this is, I'm just now's about to leave. Don, this is every day, by the way. This is how it goes. I'm 54 years old and this is, I'm just now getting clarity on this. Let's do it publicly. There are two places called Kansas City, one's in Missouri, one's in Kansas. Yeah.
我知道。唐快要走了。唐，顺便说一句，每天都这样。事情就是这样的。54岁了，而这，我刚刚快要走了。唐，顺便说一句，每天都这样。事情就是这样的。我54岁了，而这，我直到现在才搞清楚。让我们公开讨论一下吧。有两个地方叫堪萨斯城，一个在密苏里州，一个在堪萨斯州。对。
Correct. And which one's got the G's? There is a border. Which one's got the Royals? Missouri. Missouri. Missouri's got what? Let me just say this.
没错。那哪个有G（棒球队）？这里有个边界。哪个有皇家队？密苏里。密苏里有啥？让我这么说吧。
Don, take a look at JB's face. Now JB walked on through the gummy routine. This is gonna explain a lot. Walk him through the timing and the amount. Guys, I'm still up. I'm still up from last night's chew. No, now okay, well then. We talked about this a little bit on the golf course.
唐，看看JB的脸。现在JB已经进入了软糖流程。这能解释很多事情。跟他讲讲时间和用量。各位，我还没睡。我昨晚嚼的软糖还没过劲呢。不，现在，好吧，那么。我们在高尔夫球场上稍微聊过这个。
I don't remember. I don't know if you remember. I'm sure you don't remember because your gummy program is that. No, no, never when I'm golfing. Golfing's serious business. You said that. Now wait a second.
我不记得了。我不知道你记不记得。我敢肯定你不记得了，因为你的软糖计划就是这样。不，不，我打高尔夫时绝对不吃。打高尔夫可是正经事。你是这么说的。现在等一下。
But what sports team does Kansas City, Kansas have? The Royals? He's still, he's here. Is it the Royals? It's crazy. No, no, honestly, is it the Royals? Or in Kansas City? No, that's also Missouri.
但是堪萨斯州的堪萨斯城有什么运动队？皇家队？他还在这儿。是皇家队吗？太疯狂了。不，不，说实话，是皇家队吗？还是在堪萨斯城？不，那也是密苏里州的。
Do you wanna ask Siri? Do we wanna just ask, go to like the interwebs? So Kansas City, Kansas has nothing, is that correct? Yeah. No sports teams, no professional sports teams. Yeah, man. I'll let it rest now. Let's just look it up.
你想问Siri吗？我们是要问，去互联网上查查吗？所以堪萨斯州的堪萨斯城什么也没有，对吗？是的。没有运动队，没有职业运动队。是的，老兄。我暂时不纠结了。我们查一下吧。
Okay. I hope we get a bunch of no time. Honestly, honestly, you might be right. They're all looking it up, America. I've never looked into it this deeply. You might be absolutely right. I just know you have always claimed the Chiefs. He's not right.
好吧。希望我们能得到一堆没有时间的答案。说实话，说实话，你可能是对的。全美，他们都在查。你可能是绝对正确的。我只知道你一直声称那是酋长队的地盘。他不对。
He's not right. No, you're right. Kansas City, Kansas has the Royals. Are there any sports teams in Kansas City, Kansas? I'm so sorry America. And specifically. Kansas City has had teams in all five of the major professional sports leagues. Three major leagues remain today.
他不对。不，你是对的。堪萨斯州的堪萨斯城拥有皇家队。堪萨斯州的堪萨斯城有什么运动队吗？非常抱歉，美国。具体来说。堪萨斯城在所有五大职业体育联盟中都有过球队。如今还剩下三个主流联盟。
Is that Missouri or is that Kansas? That's Kansas City, Kansas. Okay. Wait, who's in Kansas City, Kansas? I don't know. Yeah, I don't know. Boy, this is, again, we're going to pick this up. Hey, Don, how'd you get started in the business? No, I want't know. Yeah, I don't know. Boy, this is, again. This is Kansas City. We're gonna pick this up. Hey Don, how'd you get started in the business?
那是密苏里州还是堪萨斯州？那是堪萨斯州的堪萨斯城。好吧，谁在堪萨斯州的堪萨斯城？我不知道。是的，我不知道。天哪，这，我们又要开始了。嘿，唐，你是怎么开始做这行的？不，我想知道。是的，我不知道。天哪，这又来了。这是堪萨斯城。我们要继续这个话题了。嘿，唐，你是怎么开始做这行的？
No, I wanna know. JB, fuck you. You have, you're. I wanna know that. There's a little porn called Don Chalontes. And. No, I do wanna know because to me, I've seen you in so many things,
不，我想知道。JB，去你的。你，你有。我想知道这个。有一个叫“唐·若·淡定”的微型色情片。还有。不，我确实想知道，因为对我来说，我在那么多作品里看到过你，
and like Will said, always brilliant. Like, to me, you were born on screen. Like, I don't know anything about you other than the time. I was born on screen. Yeah. Other than we run into each other a few times and had lovely conversations, but tell me, how did you get,
就像威尔说的，总是那么惊艳。对我来说，你就像是天生属于银幕。除了，我除了那次。天生属于银幕。是的。除了我们偶尔碰过几次面，有过愉快的交谈之外，告诉我，你是怎么，
like, you were in theater in high school? Well, sidebar, we almost, we played around with doing a movie together at one point. I remember. I know, I remember that. I don't know if you ever got that off. I did. Did you get it off? Yeah, it didn't do well.
比如你在高中演过话剧？顺便说一句，我们差点，我们曾经考虑过合作拍一部电影。我记得。我知道，我记得那个。我不知道你最后有没有把它拍成。拍了。你拍成了吗？是的，票房不太好。
But thank you for your consideration. Next subject. Way to dodge a bullet, Don. I was trying to give a compliment and went right in the trash bin. No, but did you... Were you interested in high school? Like, how early did you get the bug? So I kind of got the early acting bug.
但谢谢你的考虑。下一个话题。躲过一劫啊，唐。我本来想拍个马屁，结果直接拍到垃圾桶里去了。不，但是你……你在高中时就感兴趣吗？你有多早就对演戏感兴趣了？我大概在六年级时就对演戏产生兴趣了。
I think I was in sixth grade. I was Templeton the Rat in a production of Charlotte's Web that was written about extensively in the Denver Colorado periodicals. You can look it up, I'm sure it's still there. Sure, no, I don't have to. Templeton the Rat. And I was single about. I'm sure it's still there. Sure, no. I'm not asking. Temple from the Rat. I'm just saying I was singled out.
我在丹佛（科罗拉多州）的报纸上被广泛报道的一部话剧《夏洛的网》里扮演老鼠坦普尔顿。你可以去查查，我相信它还在那里。当然，不用，我不用去。老鼠坦普尔顿。我一个人。我相信它还在那里。当然，不用。我没问。老鼠坦普尔顿。我只是说我是被特别挑出来的。
So, Matt. The standout was the Rat. Yeah. And when Cheetal hits the stage, hold on to your... Yeah. So I did that, but I was also doing music kind of at the same time. That's when I got involved in playing my saxophone and instrumental jazz. So I kind of was on these two tracks of really studying music. When I went to high school, I had a great acting coach, a great acting teacher, a great
所以，马特。最耀眼的是那只老鼠。是的。当钱德尔登台时，抓紧你的……是的。所以我演了那个，但与此同时我也在搞音乐。那就是我开始吹萨克管和接触器乐爵士乐的时候。所以我当时同时在学习音乐和表演这两条轨道上。当我上高中时，我有一个很棒的表演教练，一个很棒的表演老师，一个很棒的
drama class, and I was in a really good jazz band. So I was kind of on these two tracks. And then I graduated from high school. I had applied for both things, to go into music, to go into vocal jazz, to go into instrumental jazz, and also to study acting, theater acting. And I got some scholarship money from a bunch of different places.
戏剧班，而且我在一个非常好的爵士乐队里。所以我基本上同时走这两条路。然后我从高中毕业了。我两方面都申请了，去学音乐，去学声乐爵士，去学器乐爵士，同时也申请去学表演，戏剧表演。我从很多不同的地方拿到了一些奖学金。
And I kind of made- For acting or music or both? Both, I had both. But I kind of made not only a weather choice, but I think I made a choice based on what I believed I was going to be able to actually do. Because I grew up with musicians now who are like professional musicians
我有点做出了——是因为表演还是音乐，还是两者兼有？两者兼有，我两边都有。但我做出的选择，不仅是出于天气方面的考虑，而且我认为我做这个选择是基于我认为自己实际上能做成什么。因为我当时和一些音乐家一起长大，他们现在都是专业音乐家，
and who are hugely successful and incredible. And I knew what it was gonna take to actually be able to do that, go down that road and shedding and learning theory and doing all of those things that I was like, I know I'm not going to do that. And I think I'm probably gonna spend my time more being out of the house, being with other people and pursuing acting and I loved it equally
而且非常成功、非常了不起。我知道要真正做到这一点需要付出什么，沿着那条路走下去，练习、学习乐理、做所有那些事情，当时我想，我知道我不会去做那些。我想我可能会花更多时间出门，和别人在一起，去追求演艺事业，而且我同样热爱演艺事业，
so I kinda went up that road. But yeah, there's definitely science and math to music that you have to want to. And I think it kind of, I was intimidated by it a little bit, to be honest. I think I was a little, you know, I'd gotten by, I had really good ear and I'd gotten by on really being able to hear music
所以我算是走了那条路。但是，是的，音乐中确实有科学和数学的成分，你必须真心想去学。而且我觉得它有点，老实说，我当时对它有点畏惧。我觉得我有点，你知道的，我以前靠着很好的乐感蒙混过关，我靠着能够真正听到音乐，
rather than understanding how it broke down. And I was kind of wide-eyed when it would, when I'd get into the weeds on that. So I get that like I kind of ran into something that I felt more comfortable with but it's funny that the music has kind of come back around and that's become a bigger part of my career now too. But Don did you ever and and Sean forgive me for taking your question but did you ever think about you know kind of like when that when that guy dropped the uh the chocolate in the in the tub of peanut butter and they came up with the Reese's did you ever think of taking the music
而不是理解它是如何分解的来过日子。当深入到那些细节中时，我会感到大开眼界。所以我明白，我好像是去接触了一个让我感觉更舒服的领域，但有趣的是，音乐后来又回到了我的生活中，现在这也成了我职业生涯中更大的一部分。但是唐，你有没有，肖恩，原谅我抢了你的问题，你有没有想过，你知道，就像那个把巧克力掉进花生酱罐里然后发明了里斯花生酱杯的家伙一样，你有没有想过把音乐
and dumping that into the theater and going into musical theater, Sean? Five, six, seven, eight. Seven, eight. Did that ever, did you ever get into that stuff? Oh, he sure did. Let's talk about the Tonys, go ahead. Oh.
倾注到戏剧里，去搞音乐剧呢，肖恩？五，六，七，八。七，八。你有没有，你有没有涉足过那些东西？哦，他当然有。我们来聊聊托尼奖吧，请继续。哦。
Well, I've never gotten one. No, but you produced something that's, yes. But I did produce the Tonys,'s award-winning show called Strange Loop. Yes! Oh my God! That's right! With Barbara Whitman. Yes. Right? And she produced the play I just did. That's right.
好吧，我从来没拿过。不，但你制作过，是的。我确实制作了一个托尼奖获奖剧目，叫《奇异的循环》。是的！哦，天哪！没错了！与芭芭拉·惠特曼合作。是的。对吧？她制作了我刚演的那部戏。没错。
Yeah. Congrats on that. Thank you. Thank you. Crazy. Great show. But did you yourself, were you yourself at like in high school or afterwards in college? Absolutely, yes. 100%. I mean, when I graduated high school, the choice I made was to go to, I came to California and I studied at California Institute of the Arts. And we, you know, did everything there. Musicals and dramas and classical pieces, we did everything. It was really a great experience for me
恭喜你。谢谢。谢谢。太疯狂了。很棒的演出。但你自己呢，你在高中或者之后的大学里亲自参与过吗？当然，是的。百分之百。我是说，我高中毕业时，我做出的选择是去，我来到加州，在加州艺术学院学习。我们在那里，你知道的，什么都做。音乐剧、正剧、古典剧目，我们什么都做。这对我来说真的是一段极好的经历，
and a place to be able to try everything and make a lot of mistakes and not get fired for it as a result. Get ready because I love horrible theater stories, things that go wrong, so just get one ready. Oh yeah, they're the best. Before we get to one of those, can you guys extend your tolerance
是一个可以尝试一切、犯很多错误而不用因此被开除的地方。准备好吧，因为我喜欢糟糕的戏剧故事，也就是出岔子的事，所以赶紧准备一个。哦，对，那些是最好的。在我们讲其中一个故事之前，你们能再包容一下
for my lack of intelligence again? Is Kansas City, are you gonna go to the Chiefs and the Royals again? It's worn pretty fit at this point. It's tripped very, very much. Yeah, don't bring that back. So if I'm on the border, but to, no. Whoa.
我那匮乏的智商吗？堪萨斯城，你们又要扯回酋长队和皇家队了吗？这个梗现在已经快被用烂了。已经绊倒无数次了。对，别再提那个了。所以如果我在边界上，但是，不。哇。
And we will be right back. And now back to the show. So jazz, talk to me about jazz. Now I'm a big music fan and specifically classical music and so I feel like if I love classical music, I could really love jazz because it's a little easier to love. It's a little bit more toe tappy. to love. It's a little bit more toe-tappy. But I got to understand it a little bit more and I'm hearing that jazz, its
我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。那么爵士乐，跟我聊聊爵士乐吧。我是一个狂热的音乐迷，尤其是古典音乐，所以我觉得如果我喜欢古典音乐，我可能也会真正喜欢爵士乐，因为它稍微更容易接受一点。它节奏感更强一点。更容易接受。它节奏感更强一点。但我必须更多地理解它，我听说爵士乐
real appeal is knowing that for the most part it's improvised. Is that correct or is there, is it more traditionally written out in their sheet music? That is a component of it and I think the umbrella of jazz under that are many, many subdivisions and categories. It's a huge sort of a blanket term, especially by now. If you think of somebody like Robert Glasper, who I won a Grammy with for producing the album, Miles Ahead, anyway.
真正的吸引力在于知道它在很大程度上是即兴创作的。这是真的吗，还是说它更有传统地写在乐谱上？那是其中的一部分，我认为在爵士乐这个大伞下有许多许多细分和类别。这是一个非常巨大的笼统术语，尤其是到了现在。如果你想到像罗伯特·格拉斯珀这样的人，我和他合作制作了专辑《迈尔斯前传》，因此赢得了格莱美奖，不管怎样。
Sorry, your cough sounds terrible. Your cough sounds really bad. It's my second Grammy, sorry. You got a really terrible cough. Yeah, thanks Will. Let me get a little water for him. Wait, are you close to an EGOT? Two Grammys.
抱歉，你的咳嗽听起来太可怕了。你的咳嗽听起来真的很严重。这是我的第二个格莱美，抱歉。你咳嗽得真的很厉害。是的，谢谢你，威尔。我给他弄点水喝。等等，你离EGOT（艾美奖、格莱美奖、奥斯卡奖、托尼奖大满贯）不远了吧？两个格莱美了。
Oh, now you have to clear. Your throat's clear now. I'm gonna get that looked at. Okay, that's good now. You have, do you have a nomination EGOT? I think you do, yes? I have a nomination EGOT, yes, but's good now. Do you have a nomination, EGOT? I think you do. Yes? I have a nomination, EGOT, yes.
哦，现在你得清清嗓子了。你现在嗓子清了。我得去查查这个。好吧，现在好了。你有一个，你获得过EGOT提名吗？我想你有的，对吧？我获得过EGOT提名，是的，不过现在好了。你获得过提名吗，EGOT？我想你有的。是的。我获得过EGOT提名，是的。
But not... Wow. I don't have them all. Pretty fucking good. Wow. But like Rob Glasper, you look at his music and he's, you know, he spans the globe of what his musical knowledge is and his experience. And he does popular stuff, black radio, which is sort of,
但没有……哇。我不是全都有。太棒了。哇。但就像罗伯特·格拉斯珀，你看他的音乐，你会发现他，你知道的，他的音乐知识和经历跨越全球。他做流行音乐，“黑人电台”，这有点像，
I think you would think of more as like R&B influenced and then he does straight ahead, you know, jazz and standards and he does everything in between. So I think if you were to ask a musician like that what jazz is, or even if you were going to go back and ask, you know, Miles Davis what jazz was, he hated that word. He was like, that's a word to box somebody in, you know, it's about good music. It's about social music. So I think there are different, like when I get in the car and you know, the driver taking you somewhere is like, let's put on some jazz and he puts on smooth jazz. It's like, I want to shoot him. I hate it. Yeah, I'm done. You have to, Don, you have to forgive Jason, because they don't do explanations
我想你会觉得它更有R&B的影响，然后他也会做纯正的，你知道的，爵士乐和标准曲，他介于两者之间的什么都做。所以如果你去问这样一个音乐家什么是爵士乐，或者如果你回去问，你知道的，迈尔斯·戴维斯什么是爵士乐，他其实很讨厌这个词。他会说，那是把人框起来的词，你知道的，这关乎好的音乐。这关乎社会的音乐。所以我觉得有不同的，就像当我坐进车里，你知道的，司机带你去某地时说，我们放点爵士乐吧，然后他放了流畅爵士乐。我就想，我想枪毙他。我讨厌它。是的，我受够了。唐，你得原谅杰森，因为他们
of jazz on the Hollywood Reporter homepage. So he wouldn't read it. But let me just say this. We did this bit in our show Flake... Nothing. So where we did, this guy's getting ready to have this girl over for a date and then his buddy suggests he has put jazz on. And they look at each other and they they're unsure, and he goes, I'm not sure where I fall on jazz. And our joke was always that,
在《好莱坞报道》的首页上不做爵士乐的科普。所以他不会去读。但容我这么说。我们在我们的节目《弗莱克》里搞过这个桥段……没什么。我们在剧里演，有个家伙正准备让一个女孩来约会，然后他的哥们建议他放点爵士乐。然后他们面面相觑，感到很不确定，他说，我不确定我对爵士乐持什么态度。而我们的笑话一直是，
I can't figure out if it's cool to say I do like it, or if it's cool to say I don't like it, and I'm still trying to decide where I land on that. Yeah, yeah. Me too, I just feel like, you know, everyone says you should go to New Orleans for the Jazz Festival, or you you should listen to lots of... And that's a very specific kind of jazz.
我搞不清楚说我喜欢它到底酷不酷，还是说我不喜欢它才酷，我到现在还在纠结我到底该站在哪一边。是的，是的。我也是，我只是觉得，你知道，每个人都说你应该去新奥尔良参加爵士音乐节，或者你应该听很多……而那是一种非常特定类型的爵士乐。
Yeah. I'm more like, I'm open to it if there's a melody that I can hum back, like a song. I'm not open to the... Fair enough. You know, the jazz that's just people just playing... Sort of fusion-y, improvised fusion. Yeah, because I can't latch on to anything. You can't latch onto anything. You can't whack off to anything?
是的。我更倾向于，如果有我可以跟着哼唱的旋律，就像一首歌那样，我是对它持开放态度的。我不接受那种……好吧。你知道的，那种纯粹是人们在随便乱奏的爵士乐……有点融合风的、即兴的融合爵士。是的，因为我抓不住任何重点。你抓不住任何重点。你对什么都撸不起来？
What? What did he say? I love it all, because if you're really, you know, if you're- Jazz, you can whack too. From the- Sorry. Jazz.
什么？他说什么？我全都喜欢，因为如果你真的，你知道，如果你在——爵士乐，你也能跟着嗨起来。从——抱歉。爵士乐。
No, latch onto. Grab your thing and have some fun. Yeah. New chair. JB, you heard it too, right? I think I might have. So Don, so you're learning the saxophone at an early age. That gets you into music.
不，是“抓住重点”。抓住你的东西，好好乐一乐。是的。新椅子。JB，你也听到了，对吧？我想我大概听到了。所以唐，你很小的时候就开始学萨克斯风了。这把你引入了音乐的大门。
Eventually you find an appreciation for Miles Davis. And then that project comes about. Was that a documentary that you produced? No, no. A movie. A film. And you played him, yes? Yes. We're not good journalists. Brilliantly, and I remember you telling me
最终你开始欣赏迈尔斯·戴维斯。然后那个项目就诞生了。那是一部你制作的纪录片吗？不，不。一部电影。一部电影。你演了他，对吧？是的。我们真不是好记者。演得棒极了，我还记得你告诉我
when I ran into you, you were working on that. You were so great. Nominations or even some wins for that, I believe. Well, that was the Grammy that we got for the soundtrack, which is really cool, that one we put together with Rob Glasper, he and I put that together, so that was really cool. But yeah, I think it's a big category.
我遇到你的时候，你正在拍那部戏。你演得太棒了。我记得那部作品还获得过提名甚至一些奖项吧。嗯，那就是我们凭原声带获得的那个格莱美奖，真的很酷，那是我们和罗伯特·格拉斯珀一起合作搞出来的，所以真的很酷。但是的，我觉得这是一个很大的类别。
Talk about jokes on shows. We had one on Black Monday where I'm talking to, thank you very much, I'm talking to Regina Don, her name, the character's Don, about it. And she goes, yeah, I can never get into jazz. It just always sounds like a bunch of instruments thrown down a flight of stairs. Yeah.
说到节目里的笑话。我们在《黑色星期一》里有一个笑话，我在跟，非常感谢，我在跟雷吉娜——唐，她的名字，那个角色的名字叫唐——谈论这个。她说，是的，我永远无法喜欢上爵士乐。它听起来总是像一堆乐器从楼梯上扔下来一样。是的。
and it's thrown down a flight of stairs. Yeah. Now, in my incredible research, did you really work on The Fresh Prince? Funny enough, I did. I was on one of the first episodes of Fresh Prince, and I have a funny pilot firing story too about a pilot that didn't go. So I did the, I think it was the second or third episode
然后它被从一堆楼梯上扔了下来。是的。现在，在我的深入研究中，你真的参演过《新鲜王子妙事多》吗？说实话，我还真演过。我是《新鲜王子》前几集里的一员，而且关于那个没能播出的试播集，我也有一个很好笑的被炒鱿鱼的故事。所以当时我演了，我想那是第二集还是第三集
of the Fresh Prince where Will was still super green. He's like mouthing everyone's words, you know, along with his, so he'd say his line and he's staring at you and you'd say your line. Yeah, he's mouthing it. That's such a thing. We've all worked with people who do that. It's such an actor thing, right?
《新鲜王子》里威尔当时还超级嫩。他就像是在跟着别人的台词默默念，你懂的，别人说一句台词他就盯着你，然后你再说你的台词。对，他在默默跟着念。真的是这样。我们都和这样的人合作过。这太符合演员的特点了，对吧？
Yeah, yeah. Where you're like, are you mouthing my dialogue to me, as I'm saying it? Yeah. Yeah. So he was so studious. You know, he knew everybody's lines, and then he would like mouth everybody's lines.
对，对。你会想，我是说台词的时候，你是在跟我一起默默念我的台词吗？对。对。所以他当时太用功了。你知道，他把所有人的台词都背下来了，然后他就会默默地念所有人的台词。
But so we did that one, and by the third or fourth show, the creators, Susan and Andy Borowitz, who were the head writers on the show, they said, we want to do a show around you. Not necessarily based on the character that you're playing on this, but we just want to do a show around you. And I was like, okay, that's cool.
但我们拍了那一集之后，到了第三或第四集，创作者苏珊和安迪·鲍罗维茨——也就是该剧的首席编剧，他们说，我们想以你为中心拍一部剧。不一定基于你在这部剧里扮演的角色，但我们就是想围绕你拍一部剧。我当时就想，好吧，这挺酷的。
So they wrote this show. How old were you? When I did Fresh Prince. Yeah, early 20s. Is that really Jermaine to the story? I mean, he's just gonna come in with the out your own show. It's like I was six. Okay When are you getting offers for your own show and he's like I worked my whole life Michael Landon did it create a show for me. Sorry, I know that
于是他们写了这部剧。你当时多大？我演《新鲜王子》的时候。对，20岁出头。这跟故事有直接关系吗？我的意思是，他突然提到有自己的剧。就好像我当时6岁一样。好吧，什么时候你才会收到属于你自己的剧集邀约，而他就像是在说我一生都在努力，迈克尔·兰登为我创作了一部剧。抱歉，我知道那
So do I this so I did so third day they come down they're like we we wanna do the show. I said, okay, great. So they wrote this pilot. We shot the pilot. It's called In the House. I wrote the theme song to the thing. It was just, everything was great. Heavy saxophone. Super, super heavy saxophone.
我也是。所以第三天他们走过来，说我们想做这个节目。我说，好的，太棒了。于是他们写了这个试播集。我们拍了试播集。剧名叫《In the House》。我还给它写了主题曲。一切都很好。重低音萨克斯。超级，超级重的萨克斯。
It was on the schedule. And I'm pretty like, I don't believe it until I see it. And I just kind of wasn't believing that it was real. And also, it just was a huge thing. It was the biggest thing that had happened in my career at that point. I was like, I don't, something's telling me this isn't real, but it was on the schedule. It was going. So like the day before I got this faithful call, I gave my brother my car, I was like, hey, it's on, take the car, I'm about to have this huge windfall. Yeah.
它上了排片表。而我这人比较倾向于眼见为实。我有点不敢相信那是真的。而且这也是一件大事。那是当时我职业生涯中发生的最大的一件事。我心想，不会吧，有什么在告诉我这不是真的，但它的确在排片表上了。事情正在推进。所以就在我接到那个重要电话的前一天，我把我的车给了我兄弟，我说，嘿，要播了，你把车开走吧，我马上就要发大财了。对。
I'm ready, and the next day I got a call and they said it's off the schedule. How old I was was Brandon Tartikoff was still running NBC at that time. Okay, we're late 80s. I don't know if people are listening now, no. Yeah, Brandon, yeah. But when he stepped down and Warren Littlefield came in and he killed all the shows
我已经准备好了，结果第二天我接到电话，他们说这剧被从排片表上撤了。当时布兰登·塔蒂科夫还在掌管NBC。好吧，那是80年代末。我不知道现在听播客的人知不知道，不。对，布兰登，对。但当他卸任，沃伦·利特尔菲尔德接任后，他砍掉了所有
that were all Brandon. And that was one of them. That was one of the cast. You know, Sean, Sean, you told me your story and correct me if I'm wrong about where you shot the pilot because they had mignonette sauce instead of cocktail sauce for your oysters. Is that true?
属于布兰登时期的节目。而那部剧就是其中之一。那是其中之一。你知道，肖恩，肖恩，你之前跟我讲过你的故事，如果我记错了请纠正我，关于你在哪里拍的试播集，因为他们用的是红葱醋酱而不是鸡尾酒酱来配你的生蚝。这是真的吗？
And you guys were about to leave Van Nuys and you were so mad. You were shocked. Because you were like, I hate Mignonette sauce. I like cocktail sauce. And you shot the pilot after Mignonette sauce. But I spared the co-pilot. As a lesson so he could live to tell the story to other pilots about to get the sauces right.
然后你们当时正要离开范奈斯，你气坏了。你震惊了。因为你当时说，我讨厌红葱醋酱。我喜欢鸡尾酒酱。你在用了红葱醋酱之后才拍了试播集。但我放过了副驾驶。作为一个教训，这样他就能活下来，把这个故事讲给其他即将选错酱料的飞行员听。
Now, all right. So now Don, could you imagine if that show had taken off, became a big success, you would have been a big sitcom star, I wonder where your career would have gone and what would have happened. I was thinking the same thing. But like, even, so going back before that, was there another significant fork in the road,
好了，现在。那么唐，你能想象如果那部剧当时火了，大获成功，你会成为一个大情景喜剧明星，我真想知道你的职业生涯会走向何方，会发生什么。我也在想同样的事情。但是，甚至，所以回到那之前，还有没有另一个重要的十字路口，
either where you grew up, like a fateful move to a certain city or what your parents were doing or saying or sibling, where you could have easily seen, oh, if I'd just simply gone right instead of left, I would be a veterinarian today, or I would be an architect today, or was there a fork that would clearly? That's such a good question.
不管是在你长大的地方，比如对某个城市的一场命运般的搬迁，还是你父母当时在做什么、说什么，或者是兄弟姐妹，让你觉得完全可以预见，哦，如果我当时简单地向右转而不是向左转，我今天就会成为一名兽医，或者我今天就会成为一名建筑师，或者是否存在一个能清晰指明方向的转折点？这真是个好问题。
Thank you. I mean, it's crazy that my fallback was music. Like, if this acting thing doesn't work out, I'll be a jazz musician. That'll get me there. It's like... So, I mean, that's where I was trending. That's what I wanted to do. And quite honestly, there's still no greater pleasure that I have,
谢谢。我的意思是，我的退路竟然是音乐，这太疯狂了。就像，如果演戏这条路行不通，我就去当个爵士乐手。那也能让我到达目的地。这就像是……所以，我的意思是，那就是我当时的发展趋势。那是我当时想做的事。坦白说，到现在为止，无论在任何形式的表演中，带给我最大的快乐依然是
you know, in any sort of performance capacity than being with musicians and creating music. Still, that's to me the highest. It really is. I think because of, as you were talking about, improvisation, that you're creating things spontaneously. I don't know what it's doing biochemically to you, but I'm sure if you have electrodes on and they were testing you,
和音乐人在一起，创作音乐。对我来说，那依然是至高无上的体验。真的。我想，正如你刚才所说，因为即兴创作，你会自发地创造出一些东西。我不知道它在生化层面上对你做了什么，但我敢肯定，如果你身上贴满电极，他们对你进行测试，
you're getting dopamine hits that are just through the roof because it's just so alive Yeah, and it necessitates this connection with these fellow pardon the term artists that you're kind of that's right Communicating without speaking and there's a bit off and a yes and thing you get that also in acting But yeah, you do and there's also that thing you do when you perform live when you you also get that When you get that feedback from an audience When you're on stage and you get that thing and it starts to inform you a little bit They become part of your creative process because you get juice from that. I think yeah. Yeah, absolutely
你的多巴胺飙升会突破天际，因为它实在太有生命力了。是的，它需要与这些——请原谅这个词——艺术家同伴建立这种联系，你们有点……没错，不用说话就能交流。并且有一种“抛接”和“顺着对方的话往下说”的默契。你在演戏中也能得到这种体验，但对，你确实能。而且当你进行现场表演时，当你从观众那里得到那种反馈时，你也会有那种感觉。当你站在舞台上，得到了那种反响，它开始对你产生一点影响。他们成了你创作过程的一部分，因为你从那里汲取了活力。我想是的。是的，绝对是的。
You do and and it transcends language and it transcends, you know English Spanish we can all speak this language. And so there's a big unifying thing that it does that's just like beyond. I had the same thing, Don. I always had music to fall back on should the acting thing, and I still have the music to fall back on
你确实会，而且它超越了语言，超越了英语、西班牙语，我们所有人都能说这种语言。所以它有一种强大的统一力量，那种感觉简直难以言表。我也有过同样的感受，唐。如果演戏不行的话，我一直都有音乐可以作为退路，而且如果演戏行不通的话，
if the acting thing doesn't work out. But I always thought my fallback was gonna be, oh, I'll just be a pop star. Well, you can take your ass off, so you had a shot. Well, no, but when I was younger. Can we just play a little bit of it right now? We do this every once in a while, Don. Sean?
我依然有音乐作为退路。但我一直以为我的退路会是，哦，我只要当个流行巨星就行了。好吧，你挺会脱身的，所以你当时确实有机会。好吧，不，但我年轻的时候。我们现在能稍微播放一小段吗？我们每隔一段时间就会这么做一次，唐。肖恩？
Yeah, no. Now, Don, do you? Don, do you? Bennett's gonna find it for us, and he's gonna play before Don leaves. Bennett or Rob are gonna play. Drop that needle, Bennett. Hey, Don, do you have a place where you go,
好吧，不。现在，唐，你有吗？唐，你有吗？贝内特会帮我们找到它，他会在唐离开之前放给我们听。贝内特或者罗布会放的。放下唱针，贝内特。嘿，唐，你有没有这样一个地方，
like Woody Allen famously took his clarinet out on a once a week or whatever and that that's not a you know that but you're my favorite guy on the podcast a place where you go whip out your sax and go play it. I just said Will got that one. You don't have to jump on top of Will's thing. Hey, hear what I did? Jump on top of Will's thing. Your turn, Sean. Get in there.
就像伍迪·艾伦众所周知的，每周拿单簧管出去吹一次什么的，那不是一个，你知道的，但你是我在播客里最喜欢的人，你有没有一个地方可以掏出你的萨克斯去吹奏？我刚才说过威尔接住了那个梗。你不用抢在威尔的话头上面。嘿，听到我刚才做了什么吗？抢在威尔的话头上面。轮到你了，肖恩。加入进来。
I'll take it off. Like, but like, do you have, take it off. There it is. Do you have a band that you play with or a jazz club that you go to every once in a while? No, and I've been bouncing around on, so I played the sax and then I didn't do that. When I went to Cal Arts, it was kind of like a conservatory, the amount of time that you had to spend on all that.
我把它拿下来。就像，但是，你有没有，把它拿下来。就是那个。你有没有一个和你一起演奏的乐队，或者一个你偶尔会去的爵士乐俱乐部？没有，我一直在四处游荡，所以我吹过萨克斯，然后就没吹了。当我进入加州艺术学院时，那有点像是一个音乐学院，你必须花大量时间在所有那些事情上。
There was no time really to do anything but theater and voice and movement and dance and all that stuff. So I just kind of dropped it. And then I was in New York doing a play and I walked by a pawn shop and I saw this beautiful tenor sax and I was like, I'm going to pick it back up again. I'm going to see if I have any facility because you know, you lose your embouchure, you lose that musculature to be able to play it. It's hard to get it back.
除了戏剧、声乐、形体、舞蹈以及所有这些东西之外，根本没有时间做别的。所以我基本上就把它放下了。后来我在纽约演一出戏，路过一家当铺，我看到了这把漂亮的次中音萨克斯，我就想，我要把它重新捡起来。我要看看自己还有没有功底，因为你知道，你会失去口型，失去吹奏所需的肌肉群。很难再把它找回来。
So I started playing it again. It sounded terrible. I was like, no, just hang out. Just like stay with it. So I started doing that. And then I took a gig actually, the Rat Pack movie and playing Sammy Davis Jr. who played drums and played trumpet and you know, gun twirled and could play piano. And so I kind of went back to school again, having private, you know, having lessons from all of these teachers to learn
所以我开始重新练习。它听起来太糟糕了。我心想，不，坚持住。就，坚持下去。所以我开始这么做。然后我接了个活儿，实际上是拍那部“鼠党”电影，扮演小萨米·戴维斯，他会打鼓，会吹小号，而且你知道，会耍枪花，还会弹钢琴。所以我有点像重新回到了学校，向所有这些老师上私教课，学习
how to do all these different things. And that's when I started trying to pick up the trumpet, which became something that was going to, I didn't know I was going to need later when I did the Miles Davis thing. So I've been playing bass more than anything lately, and piano more than anything lately. I haven't gone back to the sax. I did bring, I bought a really beautiful brand new sax
如何做所有这些不同的事情。也就是在那时，我开始尝试拿起小号，这成了我后来在拍迈尔斯·戴维斯电影时会用到的东西，虽然当时我并不知道自己以后会需要它。所以最近比起其他乐器，我弹贝斯更多一些，弹钢琴也比其他乐器多。我还没有重新拿起萨克斯。我确实带了，我买了一把非常漂亮全新的萨克斯，
and let this dude play and he just recorded an album with it. And it's like, so it's always in the periphery somewhere, but I haven't, you know, I think the most amazing experience I had in musical experience in the last couple of years was Rob Glasper was at his, he was recording something. He said, hey, come by, come listen. And I said, yeah, keep a track open
然后让这家伙演奏，他刚刚用它录制了一张专辑。所以它总是存在于周边的某个地方，但我还没有，你知道的，我想我这几年有过最棒的音乐体验是，罗布·格拉斯帕当时在录制一些东西。他说，嘿，过来看看，来听听。我说，行，给我留个音轨，
because I'm gonna bring the bass and I'm just gonna like, you know, kill you guys with some shit. So just keep the track open. I was completely joking. And so I came over and I listened to him for a while and he goes, okay, here's the bass, let's go. I said, no, no, no, I was joking.
因为我要带贝斯来，然后我打算，你知道的，用一些厉害的演奏把你们秒杀。所以留着音轨别关。我完全是在开玩笑。然后我走过去听了他演奏一会儿，他说，好了，贝斯在这儿，我们开始吧。我说，不，不，不，我开玩笑的。
I don't want to play. He's like, oh no, you're going to play. And it became sort of like, you know, trial by fire. And I don't play like that, but when you play with great musicians, you know that they lift you up. Yeah. It's just like acting. I wish they lift you up. Yeah. And they... It's just like acting.
我不想弹。他说，哦不，你要弹的。这有点像，你知道的，烈火试炼。我平时不这么弹，但当你和伟大的音乐家一起演奏时，你知道他们会提升你的境界。是的。就像演戏一样。我希望他们能提升你。是的。而且他们……就像演戏一样。
I wish I could find that. Yeah. People to lift me up. It's fucking unbelievable. I'm just dragging these two. You're just stuck with these guys. Don, you seem to be like so great at surrounding your life with the things that mean, you know,
我要是能找到那种感觉就好了。是的。能提升我的人。这真是太难以置信了。我只是在拖累这两个家伙。你只能跟这几个家伙耗着了。唐，你似乎非常擅长在生活中围绕着那些意味着——你知道的，
have great value to music, acting, family. You always seem to be in a great mood too. Is golf, yeah. How do you do that? How do you, for people who don't know how to do that, where they're like, I'm in this rut. To us, we've all found the thing that we love to do, or things we love to do.
对音乐、演戏、家庭有巨大价值的事物。你似乎也总是保持着极佳的心情。高尔夫，是的。你是怎么做到的？对于那些不知道该怎么做、感觉自己陷入 rut（泥潭）的人来说。对我们而言，我们都找到了自己热爱的事物，或者热爱的事物们。
How did you learn how to gravitate towards the good versus the bad? You know, the things that are good for you, the things that fill your soul. This is a question. This is a question. This is an interviewer, Will. This is somebody who knows how to shape a question, okay?
你是如何学会向好的方面靠拢，而不是坏的方面的？你知道的，那些对你有益的事物，那些滋养你心灵的事物。这个问题问得好。这个问题问得好。这是一个真正会提问的采访者，威尔。这是一个懂得如何构建问题的人，好吧？
Sorry, go ahead, Don. I love the commentary. I'm just here for the potshots from the sideline, man. You know that. Will's killing, and you're killing the potshots from the sideline, by the way. Thank you, I appreciate it, man. Yeah. Don't encourage him. I honestly have to attribute it a lot of it after tribute a lot of it to
抱歉，你继续，唐。我很喜欢这些解说。我来这儿就是为了听场边的冷枪暗箭的，老兄。你懂的。威尔说得很棒，而你在场边的冷枪暗箭也打得很准，顺便说一句。谢谢，我很感激，老兄。是的。别鼓励他。我老实说，我必须把很大一部分功劳归功于
My upbringing I was very fortunate to have and and people get to it. However, they get to it You know, I was very fortunate to have really solid parents, you know Really sort of you know corny traditional picket sort of, you know, corny, traditional picket fence, three, you know, the 3.5 kids and a dog and the whole thing. I really was able to grow up like that with parents that never dissuaded me from going after what I wanted to go after. I think it was, you know, really fortunate that my mom was sort of a frustrated,
我的成长经历。我非常幸运能够拥有——人们总是会以各自的方式得到这些——我非常幸运能拥有真正踏实的父母，你知道的，那种非常传统的、带白栅栏的、中产阶级式的，你知道的，老派的、传统的带白栅栏的房子，三点五个孩子，一只狗，诸如此类。我确实是在那样的环境中长大的，我的父母从没有打消过我去追求自己想追求的事物的念头。我觉得，你知道的，我很幸运，我妈妈有点像是一个怀才不遇的、
you know, performer, a frustrated singer. So when I wanted to be an actor, she was like, yes. So after that. Do you have an older sibling that knocked the crap out of you when you got too big? Yeah, well, she's a girl, so I took advantage of the different muscles. I was stronger than her.
你知道的，表演者，一个怀才不遇的歌手。所以当我想成为一名演员时，她就说：好啊。所以在那之后。你有没有一个会在你得意忘形时把你揍得屁滚尿流的哥哥或姐姐？对，好吧，她是个女孩，所以我利用了不同肌肉群的优势。我比她力气大。
And then we moved into weapons, and that's when I was like, oh, she's leveled the playing field, so we got to chill out. And that's when we stopped fighting. Just really close knit family and it's something I think I just wanted to replicate in my life. I'm really lucky that I have friends from when I was in elementary school still and from college. The people that I'm close to are still in my life. I think we all know people who have gotten
然后我们开始使用武器，那时我就想，哦，她把竞争环境拉平了，所以我们得冷静点。也就是在那时我们停止了打架。这是一个非常紧密的家庭，我觉得这正是我想要在自己的生活中复制的东西。我很幸运，小学时的朋友和大学时的朋友直到现在都还在联系。我亲近的人现在依然在我的生活中。我想我们都认识这样的人，他们到了
to a certain place and have looked around and they don't know anybody that's, no one that around them has been around them for five years and you go, that person's probably gonna have some problems. So you need people who will laugh at you and say, you're not important, chill out. I don't keep those people around because people can't breathe the air up here the way I can.
某个人生阶段，环顾四周，却发现不认识任何人，周围没有任何一个人陪伴他们超过五年，然后你就会想，那个人接下来可能会遇到一些麻烦。所以你需要那些会嘲笑你、对你说“你算老几，冷静点吧”的人。我可不把那种人留在身边，因为别人可没办法像我一样呼吸到这里的稀薄空气。
Yeah, you're one of those people we were talking about, Will. The air is so thin up here. It's so rarefied that I can bear it. I'm handing out masks to these two because I'm like, guys, we're going on a ride. We're going somewhere. Or we're going down. No, it's so important. I love that. It is a measure of somebody, by the way, how many old friends they have from back in the day. And I think, I'm with you on that.
对，你就是我们刚才讨论的那种人，威尔。这里的空气太稀薄了。它是如此高高在上，以至于只有我能承受。我正给这两个家伙发防毒面具呢，因为我在想，伙计们，我们要去兜风了。我们要去个地方。或者我们要坠毁了。不，这太重要了。我喜欢这样。顺便说一句，一个人有多少从过去到现在的老朋友，这是衡量一个人的一把尺子。我想，我和你持相同的看法。
I think it's really great. I've got a lot of my old buddies too. Now, Don, I got a question here. You've been a part of so many incredible projects. I wanna know if any of them felt or smelt like turds right in the middle of it and you were shocked at the end of it that it turned out so well. Projects like Crash, Ocean's 11, 12, or 13,
我觉得这真的很棒。我也有很多老哥们。现在，唐，我这里有个问题。你参与过这么多不可思议的项目。我想知道其中是否有任何一个项目，在拍摄正中间时感觉或闻起来就像一堆狗屎，而你最后却对它最终呈现得如此出色感到震惊？诸如《撞车》、《十一罗汉》、《十二罗汉》或《十三罗汉》，
Traffic, Out of Sight, Boogie Nights, I mean, yeah, any of the Marvel stuff. Did any of them just go, oh Jesus Nights, I mean, yeah, any of the Marvel stuff, did any of them just like go, oh, Jesus, what did I do here? I think I've had the opposite where I'm like, this thing's gonna crush, and then it comes out and I'm like, ooh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Not so much.
《毒品网络》、《战略高手》、《不羁夜》，我的意思是，是的，任何漫威的作品。有没有哪一部让你觉得，哦天哪，夜魔侠，我的意思是，是的，任何漫威的作品，有没有哪一部让你觉得，哦，天哪，我到底在这里做了什么？我想我经历的恰恰相反，我会觉得，这部作品绝对要大火，结果它上映后我却觉得，噢，行吧，行吧，行吧，行吧。没那么多。
Not so much, right. I mean, we don't know, right? You just go in with your best, you've made the best decision you could and you go in and throw everything into it and then sometimes it works out and sometimes it doesn't. But I've never, you know, I've always had, I've always believed that the thing I've said yes to
没那么多，对吧。我的意思是，我们无从得知，对吧？你只是带着最好的状态投入进去，做出了你能做出的最好决定，把一切都倾注其中，有时它成功了，有时没有。但我从来没有，你知道的，我一直都，我一直坚信我点头答应的项目
has value and it's gonna be good and the experiences and then it turns into being what it's gonna be. I've been really fortunate to have really, really great experiences. I've had very few experiences where it's a toxic set and people are horrible. I've just been very, very, I've been, the things I've gravitated toward have gotten made
是有价值的，它会很棒，经历也是如此，然后它就会变成它注定要成为的样子。我很幸运能有非常非常棒的经历。我经历过糟糕剧组、每个人都很可怕的情况极少。我只是非常非常，我所倾向的项目都得以制作出来，
and I've just been very, very fortunate. I've had a very blessed career. You've clearly got a nice connection going with Steven Soderbergh, yeah? Yeah. I heard the set of Chernobyl was toxic. Nice, Will. Hey, uh.
而我真的非常非常幸运。我的职业生涯非常受眷顾。显然你和史蒂芬·索德伯格保持着很好的合作关系，对吧？对。我听说《切尔诺贝利》的剧组很糟糕。不错，威尔。嘿，呃。
That's a great show, Will. But you and Soderbergh have a great rhythm going, yeah? You see working with him again in the future, probably? Yes, of course, right? Yeah, I mean, we have stuff, we're trying to develop things as we speak. There's a couple things. I love Out of Sight is such a great fucking movie, man.
那是一部好剧，威尔。但你和索德伯格有着非常棒的默契，对吧？你觉得未来可能还会跟他合作吗？是的，当然，对吧？对，我的意思是，我们有项目，我们正在边聊边开发一些东西。有几个项目。我很喜欢《战略高手》，这真是一部超级牛逼的电影，老兄。
Isn't it good? So underrated and overlooked. It's such a good movie. Yeah. God damn it. Despite Clooney's looks, it's so good. It's tough to get around. Soderbergh's such a beast. Soderbergh's such a good guy too.
是不是很好？被严重低估和忽视了。这真是一部好电影。是的。妈的。抛开克鲁尼的颜值不谈，它太棒了。这很难超越。索德伯格真是个猛兽。索德伯格也是个好人。
But I mean like writing and directing and camera operating and editing and I just, I would imagine that's gotta be an easy voice to follow considering he's kind of- Are you trying to dovetail into you? Cause that's what you're doing now? No, no, no, no, that's what I'd like to do. But can I take a minute to honestly actually- Oh, here we go.
但我的意思是，比如编剧、导演、摄影操作和剪辑，我只是觉得，考虑到他那种——你是在顺着话头引向你自己吗？因为你现在就在做这个？不，不，不，不，那是我以后想做的事。但我能花一分钟，诚实地，实际上——哦，来吧。
Spike it, he served it up, you might as well spike it. Guys, take you go. Spike it. Spike it. He served it up. You might as well spike it. Guys, take a second. I do want to spike it. I'm a big Jason Bateman fan. I'm just gonna say I'm a big Jason Bateman fan. I'm really...
扣杀它，他已经把球传到位了，你索性扣杀吧。伙计们，开始吧。扣杀它。扣杀它。他把球传到位了。你索性扣杀吧。伙计们，等一下。我确实想扣杀。我是杰森·贝特曼的超级粉丝。我只想说我是杰森·贝特曼的超级粉丝。我真的很……
I love everything that I'm seeing you do. And I saw you in a roundtable talking about, you know, understanding as an actor what you were going to be doing as an editor and knowing when you get into the editing an actor what you're going to be doing as an editor and knowing when you get into the editing room what you're gonna be able to use and not use and how you're gonna craft your performance based on that. And I was like, that's so fucking smart and such a cheat.
我喜欢看你做的所有事情。我看到你在一个圆桌会议上谈论，你知道的，作为一名演员，要理解你作为剪辑师将要做什么，并且知道当你进入剪辑室时，作为一名演员，你要明白什么镜头是能用的，什么不能用，以及如何以此为基础来构思你的表演。我当时就想，这他妈太聪明了，简直是个作弊码。
But really. It's really fun because he lives his personal life like an editor too. So he's always thinking about the results. So he's trying to cut you off. Fuck off. Trimming you. Well, now, what Don's doing here is he's dovetailing into his accomplishments as a director as
但真的。这真的很有趣，因为他在个人生活中也像个剪辑师一样行事。所以他总是考虑结果。因此他总是试图打断你。滚蛋。修剪你。好吧，现在，唐在这里做的是，他在顺便展示自己作为导演的成就
well. I wanted to get into it. He has gone ahead and he's taken all the incredible set experience he's had and lent that to the directing experience, right? And made everybody's life a lot easier, I would imagine. Do you do, do you, it'll come on. Why not? Bullshit, you must love it.
。我想深入聊聊这个。他继续把自己拥有的一切不可思议的片场经验运用到了导演经验中，对吧？而且我想象这会让每个人的生活都轻松得多。你做吗，你会做吗，来吧。为什么不呢？扯淡，你一定很喜欢它。
I don't anticipate ever doing it again. Why? Come on, you've done it a handful of times, at least. That was enough. Really? Why? Why? Is it the workload or the pressure
我预计自己再也不会去做了。为什么？拜托，你至少已经当过好几次导演了。那已经够了。真的吗？为什么？为什么？是因为工作量还是压力，
or the time commitment or what? It's the pressure. Honestly, it's the pressure or the time commitment or what? It's the pressure. Honestly, it's the pressure. I think, you know, my agent one time said, good actors are just like, can be and sometimes need to just be hard sons of bitches. They just have to be able to, not necessarily in how they deal with people,
还是时间投入，或者是别的什么？是压力。老实说，是压力，或者是时间投入，或者是别的什么？是压力。老实说，是压力。我想，你知道的，我的经纪人曾经说过，优秀的演员就像是，能够而且有时需要成为铁石心肠的混蛋。他们必须能够——不一定是在他们对待人的方式上，
but you have to have the ability to have stuff kind of roll off and be thick-skinned and not have it be, you know, penetrate and keep moving. And I think I have more, I'm more like sort of bandied about by the things that happen and the things I wasn't able to get. And I just, and it's something that I've learned about myself going through that experience. I'm like oh I'm a lot more porous in that regard than I thought I was. Yeah as an actor you can ignore a lot of drama or problems or complications with the production and you just kind of sit in your trailer and then someone else will figure it out. So as director you can't hide from anything.
而是你必须具备让事情顺其自然的能力，要脸皮厚，不要让事情……你知道的，渗透进来，然后继续前进。我觉得我更多的是，我更容易受到发生的事情以及我没能得到的东西的左右，我会因此感到困扰。而这是我在经历那段经历时对自己有所了解的一点。我心想，哦，我在那方面比自己想象的要脆弱得多。是的，作为一个演员，你可以忽略很多戏剧性事件、问题或制作上的复杂情况，你只要坐在你的房车里就行了，自然会有人去搞定它。所以作为导演，你无处可藏，什么都藏不了。
None of it. Yeah. We'll be right back. And back to the show. John you bring up a really good point though it is true you but we'll be right back. And back to the show. John, you bring up a really good point though. It is true, you know, actors, as we know, historically, you take a lot of heat and people go like, oh, fucking actors, or you hear people write, like even people you grew up with, like, what's your life like now you're an actor?
一点也藏不了。是的。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。约翰，不过你提出了一个非常好的观点，确实如此，你，但我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。约翰，你提出了一个非常好的观点。确实如此，你知道的，演员们，正如我们所知，历史上，你们要承受很多指责，人们会说，哦，他妈的演员，或者你会听到人们写，甚至是你一起长大的那些人也会问，你现在当了演员生活是什么样子的？
You see that people have this sort of thing. And I always say, and they're like, oh yeah, but you're just an actor. And I'm thinking like, yeah, I am friends with, I am an actor, I'm friends with tons of actors, they're some of the most creative, amazing people. And on top of that, to what you were saying, they're also, it is a tough road, as you know,
你看到人们对这个群体有这种看法。而我总是说，他们会说，哦，对啊，但你不过是个演员。而我在想，对啊，我是，我是个演员，我的朋友里有成吨的演员，他们是最具创造力、最了不起的人。不仅如此，正如你刚才所说，这也是一条艰难的路，正如你从年轻时开始做自己想做的事时所了解的那样，你确实要忍受大量的失望。你每天都要挨蛋蛋踢，
from when you're younger to start to do the things that you wanna do, and you do put up with a ton of disappointment. You get kicked in the nards on a daily basis you know my own experience I lived in New York for ten years and was trying to get fucking work and just got kicked in the nards and then as I'd go down to wincing in pain from getting kicked in the nuts I'd get kicked in the face you know like Jason's like you saying like the show's not here's the better you you you're fired
你知道的，以我自己的经历来说，我在纽约住了十年，试图他妈的找工作，结果就是挨蛋蛋踢，然后当我因为蛋蛋挨踢而痛得龇牙咧嘴的时候，我的脸又挨了一脚，你知道的，就像杰森说的，就像是剧集不在了，这是更好的你，你被解雇了，
and then the next day the show's fucking gone. And you're like, fuck, I didn't need those two kicks. And by the way, and it's not once a year, it's like two, three times a week, four years. And that's if things are going well for you because those two or three rejections each week mean you got two or three auditions that week, which is really good.
然后第二天节目他妈的就没了。然后你会想，操，我根本不需要那两脚。顺便说一句，这还不是一年一次，而是每周两三次，持续好几年。而且那还得是在你进展顺利的情况下，因为每周两三次的拒绝意味着你那一周有两三次试镜，这其实已经很棒了。
And I'm not saying to feel sorry for it, but it is, right, Don, it's a tough, you do have to have a little bit of, you show your metal a little bit. Well, for me, I really could, I sound like an idiot, Aaron, complaining about anything about my acting career, because again, I'm super, super fortunate, I've never done anything but this to support myself. I, you know, got my first job when I was still in college.
我不是在博取同情，但事实确实如此，对吧，唐，这很艰难，你确实得展现出一点点，你得显露一点你的骨气。好吧，对我来说，我真的可以，听起来像个白痴，亚伦，抱怨我演艺生涯中的任何事情，因为再说一次，我真的超级、超级幸运，我从来没有做过别的事情来养活自己。我，你知道的，还在上大学时就得到了第一份工作。
You know, my junior, I got a gig. Oh, I did get fired from a job. That was actually the first job. I got an AT&T commercial where a kid was supposed to be on the phone and sort of trying to dodge the questions that his mom was asking because he was not doing so well. She goes, how are your grades? And he's like, uh, my grades, I can't hear you.
你知道的，在我大三的时候，我接了个活儿。哦，我确实被一份工作炒过鱿鱼。那其实是第一份工作。我接了一个AT&T的广告，里面一个小孩本该在电话里假装，试图躲避他妈妈提出的问题，因为他考得不太好。他妈问：“你成绩怎么样？”然后他说：“呃，我的成绩，我听不见你说话。”
This connection is bad. She's like, no, I can hear you great. And it was AT&T. You know, you can't fake the funk. You know, it was one of those things. So I was running on my, I was going out of the door to do this audition and the phone rang in the hallway and I just kind of knew it was for me.
“这信号太差了。”他妈说：“不对，我听得可清楚了。”那是AT&T的广告。你知道的，你没法弄虚作假。你知道，就是那种情况。所以我当时正跑向门外去参加这个试镜，走廊里的电话响了，我心里隐约觉得那是找我的。
And I picked it up, it was my agent. She goes, uh, Don, bad news. They're not, they're not going to use you in the spot. I was like, what, why? She goes, they don't want to portray a black kid as failing out of college. I was like, so they're going to give a white kid my job? Wow. Yeah.
我接了电话，是我的经纪人。她说：“呃，唐，有个坏消息。他们不打算让你拍这个广告了。”我问：“什么，为什么？”她说：“他们不想把一个黑人小孩塑造从大学里辍学的形象。”我说：“所以他们要把我的工作给一个白人小孩？”哇。是的。
The irony of that. Yeah. That is crazy. That's what's going to give a white kid my job. Yeah. Wow. Yeah. The irony of that. Oh, boy. That is crazy. That's what's going to happen. So that I actually did get fired from a job I got. That was the first one. But yeah, but for me, the acting thing has been, I've been, like I said, I've been very
这真是具有讽刺意味。是的。这太疯狂了。这就是他们要把我的工作给一个白人小孩的原因。是的。哇。是的。这太讽刺了。哦，天哪。这太疯狂了。事情就是这样。所以我的确被一份已经到手的工作炒过鱿鱼。那是第一份工作。但是，是的，对我来说，演戏这行，正如我所说，我一直非常
blessed, very fortunate, but the directing part of it, yeah, it's really just, it's been these particular experiences I've had. Not when I've directed my show. That's a little bit more of a comfort zone, a little bit more support I've had, and a little bit more resources and people to rely on. But, you know, I made, we made Miles Ahead for $8.5 million in a town that had, you know, only done one other movie before that, where we would show up and there was like no redundancy in the departments. We'd have two cameras and only one cameraman. I'd be like, where's Phil?
受眷顾，非常幸运，但导演这部分，是的，真的只是，这只源于我经历过的那些特定体验。不是自我执导剧集的时候。那种情况下舒适区多一点，我得到的支持也多一点，有更多资源和可以依赖的人。但是，你知道，我们拍《迈尔斯·戴维斯》时预算只有850万美元，在一个此前只拍过一部电影的小镇上，我们到现场时，各个部门根本没有多余的人手。我们会有两台摄影机，但只有一个摄像师。我会问：“菲尔去哪儿了？”
It's like, oh, he took a commercial with Dayton. You know? Yeah, yeah. Exactly. Coming in one day and I was like, where's the... We had her in the scene. She's like, yeah, she didn't want to come today. I'm like, but she's in the scene.
然后回答说：“哦，他去跟戴顿拍商业广告了。”你知道的？对，对。 exatamente。有一天来片场，我问：“那个演员呢？我们在拍她的戏呢。”他们说：“哦，她今天不想来。”我说：“可她在这一幕里啊。”
They're like, yeah, she doesn't want to come. So I'm like, but she's in the scene. They're like, yeah, she doesn't want to come. So I'm like, put this woman in the dress, turn her back to the camera. Like every day it was something like that. Always solving problems. But the problems that didn't make sense, like the fire alarm going off, and then the actual fireman coming in
他们说：“对啊，她不想来。”我说：“可她在这一幕里啊！”他们说：“对啊，她不想来。”所以我就想：“把这个女人的裙子套上，把她背对着镜头。”每天都是诸如此类的事情。总是在解决问题。但那些说不通的问题，比如火警警报响了，然后真正的消防员冲进来，
coming in while we're shooting the scene. And so, okay, we'll shoot this MOS and just mime all these things, we'll do it in post. I get, you know, just every day it was something like that. My wife came out to see me and she said, you can't do this anymore. I lost weight, it was just, it was bad. So I have a lot of scar tissue.
在我们拍戏的时候冲了进来。所以，好吧，我们就拍这个没有同期声的画面，把所有这些动作都做成哑剧，我们在后期制作里再配音。我明白，你知道的，每天都是这样。我妻子来看我，她说：“你不能再这么干了。”我体重下降了，情况简直糟透了。所以我身上有很多心理创伤组织。
So maybe if I get some sort of procedure where I can scrape that off, I'll try it again. For the emotional scars. I have a question just about your acting style and approach because when I first saw Ocean's Eleven, which you were brilliant in, I'm not making this up, like halfway through the movie because of your accent,
所以也许如果我做什么手术能把它刮掉的话，我才会再试一次。为了心灵的创伤。我有一个关于你的表演风格和方法的问题，因为当我第一次看《十一罗汉》时——你在里面表现得太出色了，我不是在瞎编——大概看到电影的一半时，因为你的口音，
I was like, oh, wait, is that Don Cheadle? Like, you didn't do anything to your appearance, you just changed your kind of way. I don't know how to describe it. And it's amazing what an act, just an accent can do. How did you find the trust to do that? Why that character like that? And how do you do that,
我心想：“哦，等等，那是唐·钱德尔吗？”——你对外表什么都没做，你只是改变了你的那种……我不知道该怎么形容。而且仅仅是一种口音就能产生如此惊人的效果。你是怎么找到信心去那么做的？为什么选择那种角色？你是如何做到这一点的，
like in any character, your approach? It was written like that and I was going to change it. And my manager at that point said, there aren't black British people? I was like, oh, I mean, yeah. She's like, so why don't you just do it as how it's written? And I was like, yeah, fuck.
比如在任何一个角色中，你的方法是什么？剧本里就是那样写的，而我本来打算改掉它。我当时的经纪人说：“难道没有黑人英国人吗？”我说：“哦，我的意思是，有的。”她说：“那你为什么不就按剧本写的那样演呢？”我说：“好吧，操。”
Oh, so it was written as that? I'll try it. And so while I'm in my trailer with a vocal coach, a speech coach going over like diphthongs and shvahs and stuff. They're out playing basketball. I'm like sitting in my trailer watching them play poker and have fun and I'm like, no, this works.
哦，所以剧本里就是那样写的？那我就试试吧。于是当我在房车里跟声调教练、语言教练一起练习双元音和央元音之类的东西时，他们都在外面打篮球。我坐在房车里看着他们打扑克、玩得开心，心想，不，这行得通。
No, uh, no, uh, no, uh, no, uh, so. Sean, stand up real quick. Sean's wearing a diphthong. Stand up real quick. Oh, that's nice. That's a nice diphthong. But I was famously murdered. People are split right in the middle on that.
不，呃，不，呃，不，呃，不，呃，所以。肖恩，快站起来。肖恩正戴着一个双元音。快站起来。哦，那挺好的。那是个很好的双元音。但我因为这个出了名地被喷惨了。
When I was in London, I almost had to get security because people wanted to kill me based on how bad they thought that accident. They hated it and me. People literally drove, they would see me and come across four lanes of traffic to pull up next to me to scream at me about how bad the accent was. I was like, why you guys are so serious about this? Oh my God, I totally bought it.
人们对那一点的看法可以说是两极分化。我在伦敦时，甚至差点需要叫安保人员，因为人们觉得那个口音太烂了，恨不得杀了我。他们讨厌它，也讨厌我。人们甚至会开车时看到我，然后跨越四条车道把车停到我旁边，对我大吼大叫，痛斥我的口音有多烂。我心想，至于吗，你们怎么对这个这么认真？哦天哪，我完全相信了。
I totally bought it. Is it safe to say you'll never do another British accent again? Ding ding ding ding ding. Yeah, doing an accent, that would be very, very tough for for me because you're acting twice, right? You've got to do performance and you've got to do the accent.
我完全相信了。是不是可以这么说，你再也不会尝试英国口音了？叮叮叮叮叮。是的，模仿口音，对我来说会非常非常难，因为你相当于在进行双重表演，对吧？你既要做表演，又得顾及口音。
Would you make them pay twice, Jay? I know Jay very well. Would you make them pay twice? I would like to. I would like to. Are you going to say that? No, I'm just going to say and some of them, you know, fit better than others that I've attempted to take on.
你会让他们付双倍的钱吗，杰伊？我跟杰伊很熟。你会让他们付双倍的钱吗？我倒是想。我很想。你会这么说吗？不，我只是想说，有些口音，你知道的，比我尝试过的其他口音更适合我。
But they're all, like you said, it's all tricky. You're kind of acting through a mask and you're trying to make that mask be as real and as facile as you can. It's tricky. Right, right, right. Now, of all of these incredibly high profile films, which one do you think gave you the most useful bounce?
但它们全都是，就像你说的，都很棘手。你有点像是在戴着面具演戏，你试图让那个面具尽可能真实、尽可能灵动。这很棘手。对，对，对。现在，在所有这些备受瞩目的电影中，你觉得哪一部给你带来了最有用的推动力？
Was it Devil in the Blue Dress? Yeah? I would guess Devil in the Blue Dress was probably, I was on Picket Fences for a couple years before that. Oh wow. You know I was 12th on the call sheet and you guys know what that is. I'm sitting in the trailer all day
是《蓝衣魔鬼》吗？对吧？我猜《蓝衣魔鬼》可能……在那之前我在《小镇风云》演了几年。哦，哇。你知道的，我在演职员表排第12位，你们都知道这意味着什么。我整天坐在房车里，
and they're like, we're coming to you next, we're coming to you next. And they're like, oh no, we're not gonna use you today and you've been in the trailer for 12 hours. So I started writing, that's when I started writing and just as survival, just to not go crazy. But then along comes this film with Denzel Washington and it was, did you leave that project
他们会说：“下一个就轮到你了，下一个就轮到你了。”然后他们又说：“哦，不，我们今天不用你了。”而你已经在房车里待了12个小时。所以我开始写作，那是为了生存才开始写作的，只是为了不让自己发疯。但接着就来了这部由丹泽尔·华盛顿主演的电影，而且，你离开那个项目时，
with any pearls of wisdom from Mr. Washington? I mean, it was an incredible experience. It was directed by Carl Franklin, who I did his AFI thesis project, his graduation project, so I had known him from before. So that was really old home and felt great. And Denzel and I from the audition on, which is online actually, our audition is online. Oh no. Yeah. And so is that pilot that I mentioned, by the way. Oh wow. People find shit and upload everything. But we
从华盛顿先生那里得到了什么至理名言吗？我的意思是，那是一次不可思议的经历。它是卡尔·富兰克林执导的，我曾演过他的AFI毕业项目、毕业作品，所以我之前就认识他。所以那感觉就像回到了老家，感觉棒极了。我和丹泽尔从试播集开始——我们的试播集其实还在网上呢，我们的试播集在网上。哦，不。是的。我提到的那个试播集也是。哦，哇。人们总能找到各种破烂并把一切都上传到网上。但我们
just had a great time. And of course I was was just in awe of him, and worked as hard as I've ever worked on anything to make sure I was in the pocket when I was with him. I didn't come out, I was super Method-y, I was not great character, I was mouse all the time. I just stayed in it, and yeah, I had a great experience. I loved that movie, and I loved that experience. Would you, if you had, say you had a scene with,
当时度过了一段非常美好的时光。当然，我对他崇拜得五体投地，并且为了确保和他在戏里时能合拍，我付出了我做任何事时都未曾有过的巨大努力。我没有出戏，我超级“方法派”，我当时不是什么好相处的角色，我一直都像个闷葫芦。我就一直保持在那种状态里，是的，我有一段美妙的经历。我爱那部电影，也爱那段经历。如果你有，比如说你有一个场景，
because you're Denzel now to a young actor if you were to do a film with it, what would you say to a young actor today that you wish you'd known back when you were just starting out? Stay out of my fucking light. Right, exactly. Would you upstage me or shadow me?
因为你现在对年轻演员来说就像丹泽尔一样，如果你要拍一部电影，你会对当今的年轻演员说些什么？你希望自己刚出道时就知道这些。离老子的灯光远点。对，绝对的。你会抢我的戏或者挡我的光吗？
Don't you dare attempt to overshadow me. But we do have a tendency to overcomplicate things, right? And things get more simplistic as we get older. I wonder, aside from just that generality, is there anything specific, I'm trying to think myself what I would tell somebody, you know Probably probably step away from my BMW Which which of your BMWs that's a great I just think that you know, like we I think people
你敢试图盖过我的风头。但我们确实有把事情过度复杂的倾向，对吧？随着年龄增长，事情反而变得更简单了。我在想，除了这种泛泛而谈之外，有没有什么具体的——我自己也在想要是对别人说我会说些什么，你知道的——大概是，离我的宝马远点。你的哪辆宝马？这真是一个……我只是觉得，你知道的，就像我们——我只是觉得，你知道的，就像我们——我真的觉得人们
I just think that, you know, like we, I think people underestimate, you know, to what Will was saying earlier, what we really do. I think people think it's super, super easy and then they try it and they're like, oh, you're actually trying to be very naturalistic inside a completely unnatural environment where somebody's standing in your eyeline chewing gum and you know, somebody's making noise off, somebody's standing in your eyeline chewing gum
我只是觉得，就像威尔刚才所说的，人们低估了我们真正所做的事。我觉得人们以为这超级、超级简单，然后他们去尝试了，结果就会说：“哦，原来你是在一个完全不自然的环内，试图表现得非常自然，而旁边有人在嚼口香糖，你知道的，旁边有人在制造噪音，旁边有人在嚼口香糖，
and somebody else is making noise off, somebody's walkie talkie's going off, and you've got to act like this is the first time you've ever done or said any of these things. And I think that you only do that well if you're really prepared and you've really done your homework and you're not here just because you think
还有人在制造噪音，对讲机一直在响，而你还得表现得好像这是你第一次做或说这些事情一样。”我觉得，只有当你真正做好了准备、做足了功课，而不是仅仅因为你觉得在餐厅里说台词很酷才来这里时，你才能把这件事做好。这真的不是，我们不是火箭科学家，我们也不是从飞机上跳伞或者干其他最难的苦力活，但这里面确实有门道。
it's going to be cool to cut line at a restaurant. It's like, this is really, we're not rocket scientists and we're not jumping out airplanes or whatever the hardest shit there is to do or ditch digging, but there is a craft. But we can play them. That's what we play the shit out of. And we learn about them, that's another thing.
不过我们可以把那些角色演得活灵活现。这就是我们把那些角色吃透的原因。我们去了解他们，这也是另一回事。优秀的演员都是好学生，所以我们永远在实验室里，对吧？我们总是在尝试……如果我扮演一个医生，我要阅读关于医生的书。我要去观察医生。我要去医院。我要试着坐在他们旁边。如果我扮演一个警察，我要去跟车巡逻。我要去……所以我觉得这部分往往被忽视了。
Good actors are students, so we're always in the lab, right? We're always trying to... If I play a doctor, I'm going to read up on doctors. I'm going to follow doctors. I'm going to go to hospitals. I'm going to try to sit next to them. If I'm playing a cop, I'm going to do a ride-along. I'm going to... So I feel like that part of it often gets overlooked,
优秀的演员都是学生，所以我们总是在实验室里，对吧？我们总是在努力……如果我演一个医生，我会去了解医生。我会去关注医生。我会去医院。我会试着坐在他们旁边。如果我演一个警察，我会去跟车巡逻。我会去……所以我觉得这部分往往被忽视了，
that we're always in school. You know, we're always trying to learn new things. So I think that's a great boon for us as artists, that we're always expanding ourselves. Now, Sean doesn't want you to get away without, you know, searching your memory for a really tough theater story, you know, like forgetting your lines or trying to give, you know.
我们一直在学校。你知道的，我们总是在尝试学习新东西。所以我觉得这对我们艺术家来说是一件大好事，我们一直在拓展自己。现在，肖恩可不想让你轻易逃过去，你知道的，得让你搜肠刮肚讲一个特别惨的剧场故事，你知道的，比如忘词或者试图去。
Something going wrong. A sandbag fell from above. And I landed in the first row in the woman's lap and she said, you think you're drunk, wait till O'Toole comes out or something like that. Right, Sean, is that what you were at? Oh, you were at that performance. You were there.
出丑。有个沙袋从上面掉了下来。结果掉到了第一排一个女人的大腿上，她说，你以为自己是喝醉了，等着奥图尔上台或者类似的话。对吧，肖恩，你当时也在场吗？哦，你当时就在那场演出。你在现场。
That's exactly right. But I said, wait till my tool comes out. Oh, yes! Double guns! Yes! Double guns. Double guns. Yes! Don Chalant!
完全正确。但我说，等我那话儿出来。哦，耶！双枪！耶！双枪。双枪。耶！漫不经心！
Don Chalant. Don Chalant strikes again. Is that you, Sean? Oh, this is me singing, yeah. It's horrible. Here we go. It's so bad. I'm like, okay.
漫不经心。漫不经心再次出击。那是你吗，肖恩？哦，这是我在唱歌，对。太难听了。我们开始吧。太糟糕了。我当时想，好吧。
That's enough. Is that Tabla? Is that Tabla? Is that Tabla? Is that Tabla? Is that Tabla? Is that Tabla? Is that Tabla? Is that Tabla? Is that Tabla? Is that's enough. Is that Tabla?
够了。那是塔布拉鼓吗？那是塔布拉鼓吗？那是塔布拉鼓吗？那是塔布拉鼓吗？那是塔布拉鼓吗？那是塔布拉鼓吗？那是塔布拉鼓吗？那是塔布拉鼓吗？那是塔布拉鼓吗？那够了。那是塔布拉鼓吗？
Is that some Tabla? Okay, that's good. It's like Jimmy Summerville from Bronski Beat was put in the back of a van and driven to Beirut and forced to make a Middle Eastern dance record. Jimmy Summerville in Beirut. That was the name of the album. Oh, Sean. Yeah, did you ever see, by the way,
那是某种塔布拉鼓吗？好吧，这就对了。这感觉就像把来自布朗斯基乐团的吉米·萨默维尔塞进一辆面包车里，拉到贝鲁特，然后强迫他录制一张中东舞曲唱片。贝鲁特的吉米·萨默维尔。这就是专辑的名字。哦，肖恩。对啊，顺便问一下，你有没有看过
did you ever see Ricky Gervais's music videos or anything? Oh yeah, those were tough. Really? Yes. That's what, that's a similar path. But yeah, do you have any like tragic, horrible theater gone wrong? My tragic, the most tragic thing,
你有没有看过瑞奇·热维斯的音乐视频之类的？哦，对，那些太难顶了。真的吗？是的。那是一个，那是一条相似的路。不过，话说回来，你有没有遇到过什么悲惨、可怕的剧场事故？我最惨的，最惨的事，
other than a real injury that I suffered during a play, same play by the way, we were doing Cymbeline at the Public that Joanne Akilaitis directed, who is experimental director from Mabu Minds, if people wanna go back and look at all that stuff, she's great. But we had an actor, Stefan Schnabel, who played the doctor in this play.
除了我在排练中受过的严重受伤——顺便说一句，是同一部戏——我们在纽约公共剧场排演莎士比亚的《辛白林》，由琼·阿基拉蒂斯执导，她是玛布矿山剧团的实验导演，如果大家想去回顾一下所有那些作品的话，她真的很棒。但我们有个演员叫斯特凡·施纳贝尔，他在剧中扮演医生。
And you know, it's kind of a stereotypical Shakespeare fifth act wrap-up where one character knows everything that happened in the play. Like, you're his niece, and she actually has the potion. And this king knew him. Like they unwrapped the whole thing and we're all on stage going, oh, that's how, dah, dah, dah. So he had this last speech that he had to give. Stefan was, I think, 98 at the time.
你知道的，这是那种典型的莎士比亚第五幕大结局，某个角色知道剧中发生的一切。比如，你是他的侄女，而她其实拿着药水。这个国王认识他。就像他们把整件事盘点清楚，然后我们都在台上说，哦，原来是这样，哒、哒、哒。所以他有最后一段台词必须说完。斯特凡当时大概98岁了吧。
Uh-oh. Wow. So it comes time for him to wrap this up, and he goes up. That forgets his lines. Yeah, forgets his line, goes up, forgets his lines for those who want the theater vernacular.
噢。哇。所以轮到他把这一切收尾时，他卡壳了。台词忘光了。对，忘词了，卡壳了，台词全忘了，用戏剧界的黑话来说就是“上台忘词”。
And he starts stammering and making up words and basically just sort of like, Trouble. You know, standing in place and teetering. And no one... You can't give somebody... In Shakespeare, you know, it's not... We're not doing something naturalistic. You can't come up with some... You could try to come up
然后他开始结结巴巴，自己瞎编词，基本上就是那种，糟糕。你知道的，站在原地直打晃。而且没人……你没法给别人……在莎士比亚的剧里，你知道的，这不是……我们演的不是现实主义。你没法临时凑出。你可以试着凑出
with some iambic pentameter and like slip a line there to help him along the way. But it went on so long that first the audience sort of laughed and then realized, oh, it's not a bit and stopped laughing. And then the other half the audience laughed and then half the audience shushed that part of the audience that laughed. And then the actors on stage kind of were starting to laugh,
一些扬抑五音步，然后顺口塞一句台词来帮他解围。但这持续的时间太长了，先是观众有点笑，然后意识到，哦，这不是个包袱，就不笑了。接着另一半观众笑了，然后这半观众又嘘那些笑的观众。然后台上的演员也开始有点想笑，
those two that would start to laugh. And everyone's like, shut the fuck up. And then everybody stops laughing. And he's still kind of, you know. He's still trying to pull it off. He doesn't think anyone's noticed. Trying to pull it off. This went on for probably two minutes.
就是那两个本来就要笑的演员。然后所有人都一副“给老子闭嘴”的表情。接着所有人都不笑了。而他还在那儿，你知道的。他还在试图硬撑过去。他觉得根本没人发现。试图硬撑过去。这大概持续了两分钟。
You know how long two minutes is. Yeah. Oh. I mean, you guys have died for two minutes for sure, collectively on this show for 100%. Yeah, it feels like a long time. Yeah, it's a long time. And finally.
你知道两分钟有多长吗。对啊。哦。我的意思是，你们在这节目里集体冷场过两分钟，100%有过。对，感觉时间好长。对，真的很长。最后。
She says it's not. Joan Cusack, who was the lead in it, who played Cymbaline, just finally just started saying his lines. She just couldn't take it anymore. Yeah, just took over. And he kind of revved up and got through it and then got off stage and he said, I want to kill myself. Yeah.
她说不是。琼·库萨克，剧中的主角，饰演辛白林，终于忍不住开始念他的台词了。她实在是受不了了。对，直接接管了。然后他振作了一下，把台词念完，接着下台了，他说，我想去死。对。
I have to quit. I've never won an act again. And you're like, you're 98, there's no point. Yeah, you're going to be dead soon, I guess is what Joan said to try to like, you know, bolster his ego. Good Lord, yeah. That's the scariest thing. Wow, you're gonna be dead soon, I guess is what, is what Joan said to try to like, you know, bolster his ego. Good Lord, yeah. That's the scariest thing I've ever heard. Wow, fuck.
我得退圈。我再也不想演戏了。然后你会说，你都98岁了，没这必要了。对啊，你反正快死了，琼大概就是这么安慰他的，想以此来，你知道的，撑起他的自尊心。天哪，是的。这是最吓人的。哇，你反正快死了，我想琼大概就是这么说的，为了，你知道的，帮他建立自信。天哪，是的。这是我听过最吓人的事情。哇，操。
It was really sad. Going up in your dialogue like that on stage. It's the scariest thing in the world. Right? There's just nothing. Yeah, you don't need that crap at 98. There's nowhere to hide. Yeah, there's nowhere to hide.
真的很令人难过。在台上忘词成那样。这是世上最吓人的事。对吧？简直毫无办法。对啊，98岁了可不需要受这种罪。根本无处可藏。对啊，根本无处可藏。
Right. But now, Don, you're like one of the sweetest people ever. What pisses you off? Because I can't, the few times I've met you, even today, you're always just very in the middle, very cool, calm, collected. Is there some? What's that?
对。不过话说回来，唐，你简直是世界上最温和的人之一。什么事能把你惹毛？因为我——我仅有的几次见你，包括今天，你总是表现得非常中庸，非常冷静、沉着、淡定。有什么事吗？怎么了？
I said I'm on that gummy program. Yeah. I bet he's not happy when he blades a bunker shot, right? You hit that ball right in the belly coming out of the sand trap, it's just, you're never happy. That's what pisses you off. Yeah. Immediately, but then I kind of let it go, you know?
我说我正在用那种软糖疗法。对啊。我敢打赌他在沙坑里击球失误时绝对高兴不起来，对吧？你从沙坑出来时把球直接击到了球心，那感觉，你绝对高兴不起来。这就是能把你惹毛的事。对。立刻就会生气，但我随后就释怀了，你知道吗？
I think like stupidity without any desire to not be stupid pisses me off. I don't mind if you're stupid, people can be stupid, but when there are like, incurious and don't wanna actually look under the stupidity and see where that stupidity is coming from, that kinda pisses me. And you know, as we can see, it's incredibly dangerous.
我觉得那种毫无求知欲、一点也不想搞懂自己为什么愚蠢的愚蠢最让我火大。我不介意你蠢，人都可以犯蠢，但当他们表现得像那样孤陋寡闻，却又不想去探究这种愚蠢的根源时，这就有点惹毛我了。而且正如我们所见，这极其危险。
And you know, we're in a sweet spot of stupidity right now for a lot of people. And would that extend across all sort of areas, that sort of stupidity II like whether it's history Or language or just geography even basic geography of states and cities within the country that we live Oh, and oh like you know, I'm just House where city was Been explained to them like five times. I'm like shot. This is definitely hey, no, no, no, no, no, no
你知道的，对很多人来说，我们现在正处于一个愚蠢的温床。这种愚蠢会延伸到所有领域吗——无论是历史、语言，甚至是地理，比如我们住的这个国家的州和城市的地理常识？哦，还有，哦，就像你知道的，我只是一个城市在哪里已经被解释了大约五次。我说，肖恩，这绝对是，嘿，不，不，不，不，不，不
I think wills just trying to use any It feels like a shot. This is definitely, hey, a shot. No, no, no, no, no, no, no. I think Will's just trying to use an example. It's very general. I'm just trying to get a general sense of what's going on. Yeah, because Sean, remember earlier in the show and I had a problem with Kansas City.
我觉得威尔只是想用一个。感觉就像是个暗讽。这绝对是，嘿，一个暗讽。不，不，不，不，不，不，不。我觉得威尔只是想举个例子。这很笼统。我只是想大致了解一下情况。对，因为肖恩，还记得节目刚开始时我对堪萨斯城也有意见吗。
Well, ignorance isn't stupidity. Ignorance is anyone can be ignorant. That's true. Anybody can be ignorant. Thank you, Jason. So Don, honestly, you've been a dream. You're such a cool guy. We've never hung out.
好吧，无知可不等同于愚蠢。无知是任何人都可以无知的。这倒也是。任何人都可以无知。谢谢你，杰森。所以，唐，说实话，你简直完美得像个梦。你太酷了。我们以前从没一起混过。
We threatened once. I was on a, I was, Joey Russo wanted me to get into a football fantasy league. And I said, no. And Joe said, well, just stay in the chat and talk shit, even though you don't want to play. And I did for about six months, I think. Really? Yeah, you were in there.
我们倒是有过一次苗头。我当时在，乔·鲁索想让我加入一个梦幻足球联赛。我说不。乔说，好吧，就算你不想玩，也留在群里吐槽吧。我还真待了大约六个月，我想是的。真的吗？对，你当时也在群里。
You were in there. It was great. Don and Pratt and Ru Roojo, and yeah. It was fun. It was a lot like this, just like pot shots from the side. It was a lot of pot shots. It was like, oh, there's Will. Well, you know, Will, you and Don should go out and play some golf
你当时也在。太棒了。唐、普拉特、鲁·鲁若，还有我。挺好玩的。跟现在挺像的，就是从旁边放冷枪。放了好多冷枪。就好像，哦，那是威尔。话说回来，威尔，你和唐应该出去打会儿高尔夫
while I'm on my golf hiatus. And then I'll rejoin you guys in the end of fall. What happened? Why are you on a hiatus? I got some work. He's on a hiatus because he's working. He shot an even par 70 two weeks ago. But who cares really? Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
趁我正处于高尔夫休赛期。然后我会在秋末重新加入你们。怎么回事？你为什么在休赛期？我接了点活儿。他处于休赛期是因为他在工作。他两周前刚打出了标准杆72杆的成绩。但谁在乎呢，真的？嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿。
It's not a big deal. But listen, thank you for joining us today, Don. Don, will you make me this pledge when you come back that you and I will play? Can we do that? Can we say that'll happen? 100%. Okay, great. He's the absolute greatest. Sean, do you play? This should be the foursome. When you come back that you and I will play can we do that can we say that'll happen 100% okay great He's the absolute Sean do you play this should be the foursome?
这没什么大不了的。不过听着，谢谢你今天能来，唐。唐，你能不能答应我，等你回来后，你和我一起去打一场？能答应吗？我们能说定这事一定会发生吗？100%可以。好的，太棒了。他绝对是最棒的。肖恩，你打高尔夫吗？这应该是个四人组。等你回来后，你和我一起去打一场能答应吗我们能说定这事一定会发生吗100%可以好的太棒了他绝对是最棒的肖恩你打高尔夫吗这应该是个四人组？
I I could I always say I could drive the cart. He loves to drive the cart. It's a date It's so much fun. We get him a soda We get him like a float like a root beer float and he drives on next time But it's a lot of sugar He's very groggy and by the 17th hole he's kind of irritable. A little, a little, a little grumpy. Guys, it's good. Just pick it up. We got to go.
我，我可以，我总是说我可以开车。他最喜欢开车了。一言为定。太好玩了。我们给他买杯苏打水，买个类似漂浮冰淇淋的东西，比如根汁汽水漂浮冰淇淋，然后下次让他开车。不过糖分太高了。他会变得迷迷糊糊的，到了第17洞就开始有点暴躁了。有点，有点，有点易怒。伙计们，行了。球拿起来吧。我们得走了。
That's totally me. Love you, Don. Thank you for saying yes. Love you, pal. Enjoy the rest of your day down there in Atlanta and say hi to our friend Mr. Heart, please. I will, thanks guys, great seeing you today. Great to see you, dude. Thank you, Don.
这绝对是我会做的事。爱你，唐。谢谢你答应来。爱你，老兄。在亚特兰大享受接下来的时光吧，顺便代我们向哈特先生问好，好吗？我会的，谢谢你们，很高兴今天见到你们。很高兴见到你，老兄。谢谢你，唐。
Bye, buddy. Yep, yep. I love Don Chalant, it's so good. JB, what a great, what a great, great guest. God, he's so good, I love that dude. Doesn't that your shoulders just drop when you're talking to him? Yes.
再见，老兄！好，好。我太喜欢“漫不经心”了，太棒了。JB，多棒啊，多棒、多棒的嘉宾啊。天哪，他太棒了，我太喜欢这家伙了。跟你聊天的时候，你不觉得肩膀都放松下来了吗？是的。
Yeah, he's cool. I mean, he's just, I can't even form him? Yes. Yeah, he's cool. I can't even form words. Mega talent. He falls into that category. Mega talent. And universally loved. And we say this all the time, it seems like the people who work all the time also have
对，他很酷。我的意思是，他简直，我甚至无法组词？是的。对，他很酷。我简直无法用言语形容。巨星天赋。他绝对属于那一类。巨星天赋。而且备受喜爱。我们经常这么说，那些工作不断的人似乎也拥有
wonderful personalities. Yeah, I agree. Like the kind and generous. Well, Jamie, you know, you're a director. It's a big part of your career now and your life, and when you're deciding between, you have a lot of options to do stuff with a lot of different people,
极好的个性。对，我同意。比如善良和慷慨。好吧，杰米，你知道的，你是个导演。这现在是你职业生涯和生活中的很大一部分，当你在抉择时，你有很多选择可以和许多不同的人合作，
and part of the calculus, I imagine, is who do I want to spend the next four months with? Yeah, for sure. It's huge, and it's before I even start to get excited about the idea of them coming on, and that's cast or crew. I'll do Zooms with people that I may not even see on the set. And I just need to know that they're not going to,
而我猜，考量的一部分因素就是：我想和谁共度接下来的四个月？对，肯定的。这太重要了，甚至在我开始为他们加盟的想法感到兴奋之前就已经开始了，无论是演员还是剧组。我会和那些我可能都不会在片场见到的人进行Zoom视频通话。我只是需要确保他们不会
you know, wreck it with their not being nice people. Important. But he is amazing. And I could have just gone on forever and ever. We didn't get to much of anything, which is what we do on this show. Sorry listeners. You know, we get a lot of complaints about that.
你知道的，因为人品不好而把事情搞砸。这很重要。但他真的很棒。我本来可以就这么没完没了地聊下去。我们其实什么正事都没聊，这就是我们节目的风格。抱歉听众们。你知道的，我们为此收到很多投诉。
I think that some, from some people who say like, oh you guys didn't, you just, and what they forget is like, we're just so excited to see Don, right? So it got like Don, so we just start talking. Yeah, we're not journalists. We're just three dummies that want to just talk a little bit and can't believe anyone's listening.
我觉得有些人会说，哦，你们根本没，你们只是，而他们忘了，我们只是太高兴见到唐了，对吧？所以一看到唐，我们就开始聊天了。对，我们不是记者。我们只是三个只想随便聊聊天、完全不敢相信居然有人在听的笨蛋。
So if you're like, oh, why didn't you get to what Don's favorite dog type is, we're like, sorry. We were just excited. We just wanted to talk shit with them. You know what I mean? That's on the Smartless Extras. If you want to know his favorite dog type. Or talk about vacation spots.
所以如果你在想，哦，为什么你们不聊聊唐最喜欢什么品种的狗，我们只能说，抱歉。我们太激动了。我们只是想跟他瞎扯淡。你知道我的意思吗？那些内容在《Smartless》加长版里。如果你想知道他最喜欢什么狗。或者聊聊度假胜地。
Like, I don't know, has he ever been to Thailand or Mumbai? Mumbai! Mumbai! You glaze right over it Mumbai! Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Granteri. Smart Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
比如，我不知道，他去过泰国或孟买吗？孟买！孟买！你直接把这事给跳过去了。孟买！聪明。少一点。SmartLess由罗布·阿尔姆格维特、本尼特·巴比科和迈克尔·格兰特里100%有机手工打造。Smart Less。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。